guys it's the a3 podcast
monday
[Music]
april 25th
making it drop hot and heavy what kind
of beat is this
it's like
water dub bubble wave
water
[Music]
interpretive dancing
like a water drop
today is april 25th monday we're almost
into may which is insane
guys
uh we've got a great show for you for a
change unlucky unlike you know usually
today we have one sponsor who we love
it's join honey
you know love them love that for them
also i want to say
on friday we promoted
the trading cards the 8th street trading
cards
well those have been selling crazy good
they sold like
over 3 000 packs something like that
yeah
well if you want the pack i should tell
you guys
that all of the
what we sold 4 200 packs
holy [ __ ] schneider 4200 yeah
well it's not exactly but i've rounded
up a little bit
well i should tell you guys that uh
l all the money we get is being
distributed
to the crew
i am not taking any of it
so if you do want to
help support the crew
financially no you don't they're very
pay them by the way i do pay them you do
you do i don't i'm not i'm not trying to
make it sound like that but anyway if
you buy this i'm giving all the money to
the crew
so
my goodness what a generous guy that is
very generous thank
you guys deserve it it's got your face
on it you know
true it's got your face on it too though
but i want you guys to i like to
i want you guys to get a little get your
beaks wet so
but that's amazing four thousand packs
okay playboys yeah
and that's so good it is so good and
then this goes um
what for to the end of the week what do
we what did we decide we were gonna cut
off the pre-sale on friday after the
show on friday so okay so you have till
friday to buy one and all the profits go
to our beloved crew
so there you have it
very fun very exciting
oh yeah today you know the bean the
beans and toast is just taken over it's
a sensation my life yeah okay
we did the beans and
we did the beans and toast taste test
last week
and i see i you know
conceded
that it was not bad
yeah after a lot of hub bub as did i but
the beans and toast people came for me
on reddit
on our subreddit
once again you know i got word from our
sponsors the beans and toast people were
right i'm just obviously not it's a joke
ether clown disrespectful to our
national cuisine heinz was going to
sponsor us but they've backed out now
the english
the english are very angry and actually
i learned the australians the irish the
scottish they all partake
in this treachery
the whole damn commonwealth all the
queen's men and all the queen's horsemen
can it could do canadians uh they don't
debase themselves with that well they
are part of the commonwealth but i
haven't heard too much about uh
canadians in chat do you guys eat beans
and toast
because i i've been to canada and i've
never seen that i just seen the poutine
which i get down with sure
maybe poutine is like the
evolution of beans on toast
but well what
you know so yeah i've been dealing with
an onslaught of
cancellation of beans on toast oh i'm
canadian and eat beans on toast oh and
somebody else named canada empires fall
damn empire
well we have an interesting development
on the beans on toast thing
you know i went on twitter
we'd like to do a little trolling on
twitter folks
by the way elon musk close to troll we
like to troll folks we do a little
trolling do a little trolling it's
called we do a
well he's back maybe because elon musk
just closed the deal we'll talk about
that later in the show but leftovers is
back this thursday at 10 a.m live and
i'm thinking trump might be about
tweeting by then hell yeah content baby
so we're doing it live huh we're doing
it live [ __ ] it that's a new that's a
new evolution of the show
trump's just going to come back and be
like white power
just immediately just straight out of
the gate it's elon musk now white power
so i did a little trolling on the beans
and toast community
actually the the joke was that on the
subreddit i think people were joking
about me being canceled
and um
they're making posts like your your
opinions about beans on toast are
horrageous and out you know
which i don't where's the backlash
coming from we said we liked it
it's just goofs we just didn't like it
enough i know it's just goofs yeah it's
just but still it's like come on we said
we liked it well i'm glad i at least
said that it was okay because i would
have been well anyway
i started making apologies to the beans
on toast community on twitter
starting with this one which was a
direct response
to the joking apologies on the subreddit
i said to my english fans i am so sorry
for my comments on today's show my
judgment beans on toast being gross is a
stereotype i'll be trying to unlearn
apologies to all english people who i
should not have pressed inappropriately
basically it's a carbon copy of my last
apology
the joke being
that
that last one was serious and this one
is not
who would make a sincere apology for
beans on toast
well people actually got angry about
this one
[Applause]
people were angry about the beans on
toast a joke i could have told you that
that was what was gonna happen you did
you did not consult with the council
before you firing this one off you
missed the market you saw this coming
the beans on toast uh
controversy i'm [ __ ] angry i'm so
[ __ ] happy let's just say if you
would ask me if it was a good idea to
tweet that i probably said well i
thought it was funny so and who cares i
don't regret it because it's funny it
was fine then i had to apologize for my
apology i was like oh man they're pissed
about that i better apologize for my
balled you i'm sorry for my apology on
today's twitter about beans on toast my
apology for my comments about beans on
toast being gross was offensive to some
which i truly didn't intend that was a
silly joke about beans on toast but i
missed the mark i will do
better okay i didn't actually see that
one oh you didn't see my apology for the
apology that's funnier the the nested
apology is fine
then i did a you know i did a goal a
pull
beans on toast abomination or food of
the gods
this was very interesting because i
tweeted this around 11 p.m
or no 7 50 p.m here i've got the
receipts
73 000 votes
it started at 70 abomination and as the
english started to awaken
the pull moved the sun rose on the
british empire yeah
well it also set on the british empire
because you've got 73 of the world
saying it's an abomination right
don't don't worry british people there's
a good twist on this
there's a happy ending where i'm going
don't tune up don't write my sponsors
yet
just wait
this is one i said because
all the there's all kinds of drama
t-channels whatever who started making
like
video essays about my beans on toast no
really oh yeah
boy the usual suspects okay
i mean
so this was me after apologying three
times on b zone tell self uh flageration
when you whip yourself to a tone
this is how i felt on twitter i was just
like please god
just
do just free my soul
[Music]
free my soul lord help me jesus did you
know that love ratio don't want you on
one of those tweets what
accidentally where did you live ratio of
me yeah accidentally sure
which one would never the poll on the
pole yeah oh the pole well the pole
didn't get that many likes get out of
here
let's see ray showed me though oh
ratio's a ratio let me see
rigged paul everyone is okay well that's
good actually
i'm not going to stand up for my
european friends i'm glad you did that
because
yeah well i'm sorry about rachel the no
problem i would never rachel you on
purpose no problem bro
all right i just blocked you
no wait did you see that on the videos
ian
oh i blocked it
how do i unblock him
you can't it's gone elon took that uh
ability away how do i unblock
for love i'll i'll do it
darn garnet
oh love's been uh
technical difficulties
you unblocked him maybe i'm working on
it right now okay baby's work we have
our best minds working on on blocking
ceo i can just do it myself
let me do it then you're the paragon
wait how can
oh i see i'm on the history podcast one
love why are you on it like angle like
you're on a he's canted man it's hot
today dude
show me love what the hell
what is that
i'm making a statement right here i've
invented something new
green beans on toast oh my god it's a
twist on the old classic
i gotta i gotta call love out on
something real quick
he tweeted something and he's like
whoever gets the most likes on this
tweet i'll eat and the [ __ ] fifa fish
got it and he's not admitting to it
that's not true
not true
i don't understand love tweeted
whatever food suggestion gets the most
likes i'll eat for breakfast tomorrow
morning zack's claiming the fifa fish
somebody posted this is that true a lot
of fish you mean the strowman the
strongman exactly
whatever yeah
is that true love you're so full of [ __ ]
i mean this is right it's a lie bro okay
so zach why do you think love is i i i
looked through the tweet and i didn't
see [ __ ] beans on toast i saw the
fika fish had like a [ __ ] on a like
and he's trying to dodge this one dude
they deleted it out of embarrassment
wow it sounds like a rigged pull bro
right well
let's see you eat those green beans on
toast and let us know how it feels
how does it taste oh it looks a little
dry
you don't need vegetables do you
i hate bro love is anti-vegetable
spitting it out the man can't even get
down a bite of green beans and you're
supposed to eat [ __ ] fika fish what
the [ __ ] dude
i don't eat that [ __ ] that's not even a
dish bro you're supposed to eat it dude
it's a spawn of satan i said only dish
not spawn of satan bro
uh it seems like you pulled a fast one
on euro
i actually didn't because there is proof
of it there's a screen shot so here's
the [ __ ] proof okay where's the proof
i think you need to be eating some
stroman
i'm not doing that i'd rather not
you know
kill myself
that [ __ ] is nasty dude and only boomers
likes that [ __ ]
i would never do strum in love you owe
us a strumming dude ian ate one of those
whole damn things for what i would
respond
okay i would do he's more swedish than
you are
okay i'll pay that
okay cool i'll do it next show not even
you you're not eating your words here
that's worth it for me all right
but what love for 500 bucks do you think
you could keep it down
yeah
oh i'll do anything for 500 bucks dude
really
yeah you guys are a bunch of [ __ ]
over there in america for 500 bucks is
everything i'll do anything for 500
bucks and that my friends is why
capitalism is on the verge of uh yeah
five percent
collapse
[Music]
okay i'll give you 500 bucks to crush a
whole
strowman
like not a whole tub like a whole a fish
yeah one whole fish yeah yeah yeah but
you gotta open it fresh in your small
room i know you can't be coming with one
single fish you have to open it fresh
before my eyes
i can't live stream outside
50 bucks you're not even supposed to be
having money for this
you're supposed to eat it
why are you changing the rules bro you
said anything for 500 and now you're
putting conditions on he's stealing it
okay i'll do it inside whatever thanks
dude all right well let's talk
all right cool
deal
cash is king baby that's what people are
saying money walks
[Music]
oh people are saying eat it on toast
that's interesting that actually might
make it more adorable
do you have any tips for love going into
this challenge
i've had it before just don't be a [ __ ]
bro
yeah
now were there bones and edible bits on
it and yeah they were like bow i was
like yeah
ian was ian was pulling bits out of his
mouth you feel comfortable with that
love
for 500 bucks yeah wow i think you're
being overconfident but yeah ian
impressed me when he did it so i have i
guess you could do it too
he turned to the grace of god he like
looked up and he's like god give me yeah
he did
he was praying for mercy
i i'm excited to watch someone else go
on that journey yeah it's a spiritual
moment
all right well that's exciting for our
next show
yeah i'm looking forward to it well so
what i'm leaning to after this whole
beans and toast controversy
um
is basically that
we had a response
from a very kind-hearted uh person that
we like
alana pierce
where was that conversation
took place
it was on my twitter
she recommended
it it's in the doc
oh thank you guys
so she's australian
and she recommended
she says ethan american beans are gross
you don't understand these people don't
have context
so i said blue hinds right because
that's yeah that's what we were led to
believe
she says you have to import them nothing
in america tastes the same unless you go
to an english pub
fox and hound is my go-to in la
i said okay well she cut so a lot uh
alana is coming through with actual
recommendations in los angeles
okay i used to frequent that place
over there yeah
i've been there too
oh my goodness gracious thank you sam
so we went this morning to fox and
hounds
uh which by the way sam said she got in
there at like 10 30 in the morning and
there was a bunch of dudes uh there with
beers drinking on them that's the
english way
you know it's a legit food what were
they eating what were they eating sam
no food just beer
10 30. but you were able to order beans
on toast at 10 30.
yeah isn't it is it it's a breakfast
thing that's it it's for breakfast yeah
okay
and then okay interesting interesting
uh
and so
she said also get the sausage rolls
so she so thank you to alana pierce for
the suggestions and we went ahead and we
did it we went to fox and hounds i said
god damn it i'm going to get to the end
of this beans and toast controversy i'm
going to get the real deal we're going
to do this the right way so what we have
here and everyone has one right
is the real deal my friends we've got
the hearty bread we've got the toast
okay that does look way more legit than
when we got the beans put together and
then not only that we got the this i
can't get i can't condone this but i'll
try it what the [ __ ] is this
is that meat is that meatloaf
i don't know
what's a scotch egg
well
scotch egg
uh a boiled egg wrapped in sausage meat
coated in breadcrumb crumbs and baked or
deep fried
look at this that sausage me okay
playboy
they gotta work on the aesthetics like
honestly their food is just yeah they
need to do something about that i need
some sprigs or something to liven that
up so while i say that
the sausage meat is not bad
it's like it's a three out of ten i'm
sorry
the good people are fox
maybe it's i don't think it's their
fault i think they did as good as they
could
i just don't
[Music]
you guys got food try it
[Music]
ours is still coming
oh okay
and then there's a delay in the kitchen
this is the sausage roll
which i don't know what's i mean i know
there's a sausage
puff pastry
little sausage and drive
i think it's pretty interesting that
americans get criticized for unhealthy
food
i mean this is up there with the best
this is this is a pastry bread with a
nasty sausage and cheese i mean this is
this is right up there for breakfast
that might be the greatest thing i've
ever eaten really yeah
i need to nap them that's pretty good
i'm getting a report that uh the egg
yolk should be soft boiled trash scotch
egg
it might it may not be their fault i
don't give too much hate to the
restaurant because we had to reheat it
thank you oh that's true thank you baby
you know what i mean because sam is
forced to reheat it for us
so i'm gonna give him the benefit of the
doubt yeah that could be it could be
all right
now
to the main event
here we go
anticipation killing
my friends
this is the apex
of the beans on toast debate
we have fetched it from
a fine establishment recommended by a
fine
australian woman
who's spent time in england she said
her credentials are thorough
and so with that being said
to the queen long live the queen
long live the queen
except prince
who's the prince that hung out with
epstein andrew
prince andrew prince andrew [ __ ] that
guy
this is what prince andrew eats for
breakfast
right
okay
listen
[Music]
i love my english friends i love my
canadian friends my australian friends
my irish friends my scottish friends
they're all
lovely wonderful people
love the queen and the royal family
hope she lives forever
i [ __ ] hated it i hate it
i don't like it i'm sorry
alana
i like you very much you think you're
awesome i love everything you do
fox and hound
great people good good people there
the beans taste like the heinz tastes
the same it tastes the same so would you
say you like this less than the one that
we tried i actually would
actually like the heinz one better and
i'm sorry
the heinz one had a little more
refinement in the flavor and i
i know that sounds silly but
it tastes exactly like the heinz just a
tiny bit
less sweet
um
the sausage roll is definitely slapping
but i'll just be honest with you guys
it's basically a hot pocket
i'm sorry it's a hot pocket
[Music]
it's a homemade hot pocket
[Music]
that's just one man's opinion please
don't kill me
don't write our sponsors
don't write heinz don't write the hinds
people
all right now i'm curious what you guys
think at least tell me
is it really that different than the
heinz one we had
here we go
dan is about to take a bite
dan is concealing his mouth behind the
monitor
[Music]
let the people see man
you took a bite of the toast
okay
go ahead
i'm gonna go against i'm gonna go
against you i think this is better than
the one on friday okay is it very
different though
i i can attribute
it partly to this being better bread
it is better bread yeah
but how much different is it well it's a
little less sweet like you said
which isn't necessarily a bad thing i'm
still in i'm i'm kind of down with the
beans some toast damage is strong i
don't think that's pandering listen i
wouldn't go out of my way
would you ever order it
probably
if i'm being real probably not but
i wouldn't refuse it
i don't refuse food
when have i ever refused food well
that's true
it's okay
what did you say you gave it like three
out of ten or something i give this like
a six out of ten
a six i'll give it a five i'll give it a
six out of ten
all right who's next a b go ahead
all right i don't have any
where's abs
there's there's uh you're about no i'm
i'm good i'm good what's happening i'm
good
you don't want to eat this
i have sparring today
sparring we just started the show it's
gonna be like three hours
here there's just some stuff that's too
white i can't do it
i'm sorry i i didn't try it on friday
either
i'm not trying that i'm so sorry it's
just beans i can't i can't i can't
go ahead i can't do it i'm sorry why
can't you do it i can't do it
what is this amy
what's happening right now
he's he's anglophobic
yeah wait why are you being anglophobic
that looks like a [ __ ] nightmare to
me i'm sorry
imagine someone brings a bowl of hummus
to me
they're like this is fine lebanese
hummus i'm like i'm not eating this
filth maybe like sucks for them
i think you're being racist
is there it's still ramadan right yeah
yeah he's fast oh it's ramadan yeah
but you you're not fasting because
you're boxing i'm not fasting but thank
you dan nice try i tried that's right
lino what's happening here
well it has pork in it so he can't eat
it wait whoa oh you haven't out bro i
don't eat pork
wait what yeah
wait is the beef there's pork
is there beans in the pork jesus christ
people oh crickets i think i asked them
about allergens and it's like a cross
contamination thing that's why i didn't
serve so no there's not like actual meat
in it but i didn't serve because i
wasn't sure how that worked
all right well will you at least keep it
next to you during the show literally
the smell is going to make me throw just
beans you never had bank babies
i don't think so
interesting sorry i appreciate it god
bless
so does anyone else want back there have
nobody else is even gonna try the b what
about ian he is the one who [ __ ] set
this all up
from the finest establishment we got
like us we got beans and toads for
everybody
i i don't have anything to prove to
anyone yeah i mean ian's are openly
stated yeah he's true right
we already know he's a supporter
zach try the beans and toast for
christ's sake man
lena cam
sam i have gum in my mouth how are you
guys being such divas about this
you ate arby's meat mountain and you
won't try the beans on your toes yeah
exactly because that's like quality
american cuisine you know what
why are you guys being like all right
i'll try it i'll try it that's right
you ate a whole container of mayonnaise
man
all right here we go
this smells kind of weird to be honest
bro it's not it's just beans and toast
not that bad i feel like i got to defend
the english here y'all are being so
dramatic
which is never a position i wanted to be
in no defending english
i give it a 4
4.5 but you didn't even get a bite of
bread did you i took a bite
one more for the queen
do it for the queen
ain't got much time left
went down a point went down a point it's
a four now
maybe i got to say you know
tell me what's happening you are you
have an aversion to beans i can't eat it
even if i want through this pork in it
no it's not yeah she said it's mixed
with like uh it just means that they
said there might be a crosstalk
contamination surface well technically
i'm not supposed to yeah okay wow
you got the religious pretend there's no
pork in it for a minute what is going on
there
i don't know
i'm just weird about sauces and stuff
like
i could literally watch someone have
open heart surgery and not blink but any
like watching zach eat mayo makes you
want to [ __ ] puke every time that i
get more than babies never eat sauce
yeah i don't like sauce
okay
that's good then i'll bake that
definitely for sure oh we'll bank that
cameron sam
guys it's just beans on a piece of bread
guys
stop bowling amy's you stop bullying me
about bowling a b
i'm just trying to understand what's
happening
i'm making mine right now i've tried it
ethan i don't like it
okay wow the uh the beans on i don't
like the tomato if it was like bush's
baked beans or something i feel like i
would like it like a sweeter
bean but i'm not crazy about the tomato
asp i got to agree i kind of liked it
with a little more sweetness to it
[Music]
who's eating now i hear clicking i think
cam's trying it okay
cameron human fecal matter
[Laughter]
johnny depp not a fan not a fan matter
apparently i like it the best of
everyone in here because half of them
won't even look at it i rated it higher
a point higher than you but that was
before knowing there was pork in it so
i like the other beans more the one we
had the other day
me too
you have an english man saying the hinds
on white bread was was superior i i
don't know that can of heinz i asked my
grandma i asked my dad they're like yeah
yeah that's the can so hey i don't know
to be honest i really liked i thought
those beans had a better developed
flavor
well there you go guys
heinz and blue
on a piece of wonder bread oh no
i'm seeing people say you need melted
cheese on top we're not going to get
another round of british no numbers
nobody ever told me about melted cheese
yeah
these people just add and add oh you
need worcestershire sauce oh you need
this you did no
you need a big old steamer i'm concerned
about the outcome of us all eating beans
in one room it's not gonna be pretty
what
you're concerned about the outcome of
that i'm gonna eat [ __ ] fish in my
little room yeah they're gonna be by
yourself yeah we don't have to deal with
the cops we're all gonna be farting
around here dude what's going on here
dude
i have no uh i mean i don't think it
will change my bodily functions one way
or the other [ __ ] i'm gonna get the runs
from this all right well there you have
it i mean
english people
for better or worse of all all people of
the queen's world
all people of the queen's empire
i have accepted your challenge
in every way possible cam did you uh
issue a verdict
i'd rather eat a pancake any day
that's the [ __ ] truth dan don't you
know it
human fecal matter
first of all the beans on toast is not
healthier than a pancake let's make that
clear
oh
is it i don't know
beans on soupy
sweet sauce with butter
yeah but pancakes are just it's just
flour and sugar but it has an egg in it
it's flour and sugar and then you pour
more sugar on top and then you put
butter all over it and
egg gang yeah i don't know i don't know
about that i don't think it's much
because the beans has like some protein
egg gang
there's an egg gang
[Music]
a what egg gang egg
johnny depp what do you think about
beans on toast human fecal matter that's
a little bit harsh but there you have it
[Music]
that's true there's no fiber in pancakes
there's literally no fiber in american
breakfast that's kind of epic if you
think about it like eggs no fiber french
toast pancakes bacon sausage no fiber
cereal
yeah i mean you can have cereal yeah
but that's
eating a bowl of cereal is pretty common
yeah
i'm still a cereal gang all the way eat
cereal all the time that's all lena eats
all day it's the best
it's the best
okay so who else lena you want to oh
well yeah i guess you can are you is
there okay everyone she can
all right
all right
fecal matter guys i know beans are
healthy but when you cook it in like
sugar and sauce and [ __ ] no it looks
like you're right i look good it's not
that [ __ ] healthy like if you just
eat like straight up beans that's really
healthy but i can tell you whatever the
[ __ ] is on that toast is not healthy go
ahead ap thank you i'm saying look at
the calories on average it looks like
beans and toast is more than double so
above pancakes
one pancake
then order three pancakes
yo
but again simple google search so
i
well i'm i'm assuming that those three
pancakes don't have syrup and butter on
them correct
right which will put it yeah triple
triple that count
oh no wally
i'm just saying if you look at prince
andrew you know he eats beans and toast
dude
hand to god right now i'm starting to
feel the gurgles
i swear to god you had like a little
baby
no but then i had the sausage thing
before that too which was bomb i
destroyed that sausage that was really
good but my my tummy is gurgling dog
don't you think it was kind of hot
pockish hot pocket-ish though i thought
it was better than the hot pocket
okay
just saying
now you tell me one thing
right now
this man eats beans and toast
every morning oh yeah i have no doubt
about it he puts lots of butt he
commands his servants to prepare
and then he goes and uh
let's see gourmet
beans on toast this is let's see what he
eats because you know he eats gourmet
[ __ ]
let's see what prince andrew eats for
breakfast
gourmet beans on toast no
i don't think anybody wants that
even the
the biggest beans on toast connoisseurs
oh no no no no no no
[Music]
that's even worse
that's interesting
[Music]
not sure what makes that gourmet it's
just cheese and tomato
but okay
have you ever had um vegemite before
i actually have never tried vegemite
that's the worst thing on earth
yo look at this you guys each bean
individually placed
wow
delicacy
that's prince angie's breakfast every
morning
i'm ready for supper that's what he eats
for every meal
this bean is out of place
take it back
whoa
what happened to love
beans on youtube
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait this is like an actual thing people
do where they beans are placed
meticulously crafted
this is going this is what michelin star
restaurants in england look like
[Applause]
three michelin stars
gordon ramsay's finest restaurant
it's just called beans
beans
[Music]
this is
the [ __ ] happened here
he whiz
well there you go
we gave it our best shot guys please
don't be angry yeah
[Music]
and i promise my beans on toast tweets
were just jokes there's no hidden
meaning or ulterior agenda
um
so
please
please guys
all right let's move it on we did our
beans on toast olympics you know we have
um
dad called in he was a hit before you
know he's boxing in the event a b and i
dubs are
participating in
um his opponent matthew watson hey
it's called you know he was on the line
trying to call him when dad was on
because dad was talking mad smack on
matt and so we're going to have them
both call in today and hopefully we'll
see
who can win in terms of smack talk uh
you know smack talk sure daddy
but before we get also that we have new
ace family updates like this thing gets
better and better and better it really
does the new ace family update is mind
blowing
i think we were all freaking out when we
figured this one out yeah yeah
um we are at uh 37 minutes though so we
should do our honey ad our one sponsor
join honey who we love love love loyal
kings
honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping
on your iphone or
computer
i love shopping online me and ela do it
all the time
and that specifically
makes honey even better
um
you know i used to scour the internet
for promo codes because you know there's
always one out there it's gonna give you
a huge discount
and honey basically removes that
scavenger hunt
from your life and you can rest easy
knowing that when you come to that
checkout page
it's automatically going to apply the
best one available look at how much
money we've saved 400 bucks 62 bucks
these are all real savings they eila
sent to dan
you don't even have to think about it
dude right like steven says i mean he's
not very bright but yet he's able to
even figure this out right
all you got to do is basically it
installs in two clicks
it's easy it's free
it really is so easy to install
um
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button appears and all you have to
do is click apply coupon wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
you can find for that site
funny finds a working coupon you will
watch the prices drop
you know and it works on basically
almost every website clothes tech food
furniture
um
we even ordered postmates once and saved
like 20 bucks like pulse rates
you know
yeah look at that 12 bucks i was like
what
so crazy
uh honey doesn't just work on desktop
now it also works on your iphone too
just activate it on safari
on your phone and save on the go and if
you don't already have honey installed
you're gonna be missing out
on free money and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show
i use honey
i love honey
get honey for free at joinhoney.com h3tv
that's
jointhoney.comtv please support our
sponsors guys if you're interested in
honey
thank you thank you
also since we're here why not we only
have one sponsor today
let's go to teddy fresh if you want to
uh
support the super trooper nation
you know this shirt's really nice i'm
gonna showcase this shirt
it's a women's tee
i mean you can wear it if you're if
you're a guy it's just a little tighter
but um
the fabric is really nice the colors
really pop
i really think it's a beautiful shirt
the dress is nice too i understand
dresses aren't for everyone
but like ela was popping this it'll look
really good on her
but i get i get a snap for everyone you
know dress
um
but yeah you know this is a great piece
if you're just looking for a nice
comfortable
kind of standard issue thing it's an
acid wash hoodie the fit the fabric is
beautiful it was washed in acid enzymes
to give it this cool
uh texture
and it gives it a unique soft feel as
well when it's washed in that way
do you know what i'm saying
totally dude thanks bro
also we have this thing styled by tf
i don't know if you guys know macy she
runs our tick tock
account our teddy fresh tick tock
and she did these cool
shop to buy looks where you can come see
what she's wearing and then click
and see which items she's wearing wait
did that work
[Music]
is this thing working
this thing on hello yes
the items are right there below
but
so if i click this one the dress
okay there's the dress
there's the bag wait it's all these
items
so if i click this one guys go click
around okay here it is oh
yeah it what it takes me to the top of
the page and i gotta talk to them about
that basically these three is these
items i get it guys
anyway teddyfresh.com
forever and ever
[Music]
thank you thank you
and the trading cards of course
straight to the crew
i gotta say four thousand packs
way better than
whatever i guess the 25 dollar price
point makes it a nice
entry point and it's fun it's a really
fun
item
people love the pot squad
the red squad
they're
excavator if you say that again
i'll show you pod squad
it's gonna happen
all right before we get into the meat
and potatoes here
we've got some goofs at the top of the
page
first of all dan needs to
dan you need to explain this
a lot of people got confused a little
tripped out
dan doing this on the show
go ahead watch this
puts the ear in itself and then it pops
out
you just gonna do that and pretend like
nothing happened
what's the problem
what's so special about that
do it all the time
you can't do that stick your finger i
can stick my finger in my ear
no i can't do that can anyone else do
that mm-hmm
yeah i can do that you see i show me all
the time
show me
ready hold on dude you do it all the
time oh you missed it ian just did it
wait you do it all the time love
oh you can do it too
oh hell yeah it's not
so yeah it's the i i'm not as good as
dan obviously he can't put it in for
longer but it's just it's just one of
those things you do
i just don't understand why someone
would want to do that
well dude all the time
ready ready what the hell that looks
really uncomfortable
go off kane i've never seen that
but
you have cute look like elf ears dan
well thank you i don't have i don't have
cute outfitters like yeah
they're rather large i'm well aware
i didn't say that big-ass elf ears
uh love i would like to see you do that
though you haven't proven you say you do
it all the time well you you only have a
couple of charges it sticks like maybe
three times then the ear gets too loose
is that right dan only a few charges
i consumed all my starches already uh
yeah and it it kind of depends on like
you know the humidity in the room i'm
comfy i i hate to say this thing
watching you stuff your ear into your
your hole
are you ready you ready can you control
when it comes out or you feel it yeah
you just if you just raise your eyebrows
it pops out oh for real yeah this is
very odd
it makes me uncomfy to see it tucked in
like that
i there was somebody in that reddit
thread also my ear it kind of hurts my
ear it's not like a comfortable feeling
i guess i just don't have that sensitive
ears or something it could be that
you've practiced it or that i've just
done it yeah so somebody in that thread
said some people uh
do it since they're kids as like a
comfort thing and that's definitely the
case with me i've played with my ear
since i was like a baby and it's totally
unconscious like i don't even think
about it i
do it all the time yeah i have stuff i
do like that too i mean i don't i'm sure
i do i don't know what but
there's stuff i do for sure we all do
i like to stuff my
i've done this once you ever done this
where you pushed the head of your dick
like in
no like a scared turtle i've done that
before yeah and it's just
so i can do that in a way
i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta do it
yeah of course i've done that i don't
think there's a man that happens it's
just not a good feeling but i've done it
yeah
i do it with everyone the girls are so
confused right now they're like you do
what
[Laughter]
ladies listening if you have a
significant other who's a man ask them
when you get home tonight or now say hey
you ever do that thing where you tuck
the head of your dick back into your
penis yeah they'll be like the [ __ ] you
see they'll be like you know there's
that memo ticked up
who told you that
i i have to imagine that that's only um
possible if you're circumcised right
i think so because we're we're all cut
you think so but if if you uh are uncut
you're kind of always you're always
doing it's like it's like you're going
back to
being circumcised exactly yeah do you
ever like helicopter
ever helicopter your dick
no no no yeah i have not yet yes i have
okay
okay yeah i thought that was something
everyone did you never tried to twirl it
no no twirling you ever get lift zach
yeah i don't think
like you remember air hogs
no what's air hogs you don't remember
air hogs like the toy uh remote control
air hots
i was just making a play on words there
but i
okay
yeah i've helicoptered i've done it for
hilo before i don't know
[Laughter]
definitely done it for you
for her what what a gift usually what a
gift you provide usually do when you get
the dew off the lily after you just went
pee you know
so
say what someone has to decide for that
you know you shake the dew off the lily
you've never heard that take the dew off
the lily yeah after you pee you know you
gotta shake it a few times
you do it to get urine off won't spray
in your face not like full blown
helicopter but like an up and down like
a handshake you know well that's just
jiggling your dicks all over the next
bathroom more than three times you're
playing with it two you're in the clear
all righty
yeah i mean i think every guy should do
a helicopter for his girl
yeah all right
just at least once
it's like a mating ritual like a peacock
ritual exactly it's very it's very um
primal
yeah i can see that i gotta say after um
the episode the guess who's high and you
were asking about everyone's dad's hogs
you kept saying
we went out to dinner with sam's parents
and they were like we watched the
episode we've never heard that word hog
oh no they kept saying it and sam was
like please stop that's awesome
because it was sam specifically that had
took issue with the term hog correct
yeah
that's really interesting sam that your
parents were so quick to adopt that
terminology they must be pretty pretty
uh cool and hip right they just they
thought it was so funny but i hate it i
think it's so bad
but
that's interesting because your parents
think hog is funny
but i like that i thought that was very
interesting anecdote that ian shared
it's my it's meant to be crashed though
you know what i mean of course yeah
you wouldn't like in an intimate moment
be like let me get my hug out
i i think i know somebody that would
yeah maybe
no
hang on baby the hot the hogs are coming
in yo get some pig feet the hogs are
coming the hogs are coming in the barn
girl
i don't know if calling a girl's private
to barn is a good no
room airy
well there you have it
island boys yeah i saw this and i was
curious what your
take on this would be ab
so the i i guess the island boys are
prepping or training for a fight are
they actually fighting bryce hall i'm
not sure if it's official yet but these
kids are gonna get
1v2
it's got to be two verse one at the same
time that's the only way i'm interested
the thing is these dudes are
gonna get absolutely destroyed by bryce
hall and i don't mean that as a
compliment to bryce hall
but watch this
they posted this
i've only seen reuploads i didn't see
the original but i think they did i must
have deleted it from all the hate
that's got to be the worst technique
right yeah this is
unlike anything i've ever seen
[Music]
on all aspects who's better to train
them than oh a kick
i mean that's
that is
it's
i don't know anything but it does look
not powerful okay every rule it's the
opposite tuck your chin their chins are
up you're supposed to hit straight their
arms are up
your back leg is supposed to be back the
legs are together really
right like a good punch has some kind of
like torque
yeah but that all those all come from
like the chest
yes also uc slides aren't proper boxing
shoes
no slides
[Music]
so a long boy way
so they just have their own song looping
in the background like at all times
i don't know if they if it was in the
original i was wondering that too though
yeah they do that you got a per you
gotta you gotta make sure your song gets
listened to yeah it didn't seem like it
was like added to the video though it
seemed like they had it on speakers
wherever they are oh no
it could be wrong but that's what it
sounds like to me
i think it's just quiet i think it's
just quiet
i like the idea of them just playing it
on loop at their house 24 hours a day
are the island boys ever going to go
away are they always going to be around
you know what i mean like so he's going
to be like oh what are the island boys
up to this year that's a good question
they've persisted longer than i thought
they would i thought that'd be a dead
meme in a week
but here we are i feel like if we got
the island boys on the show people would
still watch do you
people would still watch for the island
boys yeah they clicked that
it's interesting it would have been
a couple months ago for sure now i don't
know see it's interesting to get them
when they're like popping but maybe it's
interesting to get them on the down
they're not popping
well if they're fighting bryce hall i
guess that i mean that's a that's a big
thing right yeah i don't know if that's
actually going to happen
how is that going to happen because
bright i think i mean
you know about the uh i'm an incest boy
yeah i saw that
everyone's been waiting for them to kiss
and they finally did
kind of
i mean yeah i feel like there was like
two girls they're like if we do a
four-way kiss we'll make out with you
because they were trying to have a viral
moment
and so they ki well can we show that do
you think
i'm just kissing it's not that lewd i'm
not sure but i did find a compilation of
them saying they don't kiss
yeah because there's always been a meme
about them like yo when are you guys
gonna make out and it really bothered
them
and so they made all these videos like
why you guys shoot we're kids that's
disgusting we're twins i'll just give
you a big fat kiss and um well
apparently
they got pretty close to making out
but to be honest is sleeping with your
twin anything more than just
masturbation
yes yes there it is we have our answer
oh my god a quick a quick response
that's a yes that's a hard yes what if
you cloned yourself could you [ __ ]
yourself then
oh
well
these are deep philosophical questions
that are
far beyond my i mean what if you what if
you were
what if you cloned yourself
and you guys sleep in the same room now
when you make a clone in real life
the clone is going to be like a child
and like have to grow up but are you
saying like make like a duplicate
yeah just sells just cells dividing kind
of thing
i mean can a like
is there some sort of like matrix
scenario where the like knowledge from
your brain is transferred same person
right so it's but basically i mean
they're two individuals at this moment
but like let's say you cloned yourself
you're 20.
same person new person but like same
person split into
so then you're both let's say your
schedule is you get in bed you beat one
out you go to sleep so you and your
clone are sharing a room obviously
because you're homies like that
you have two and then you're both
jerking off as because that's your
ritual it's both the ritual and you're
like you know what i could really go for
a blowy right now or a handy
you'd rock paper scissors for like who's
giving who's receiving or reciprocals
could be a 69 or they take turns style
situation so
so that's a consenting act between the
two clones one clone one real
um what do we think oh let's do a poll
that people are saying i think that's a
good idea
so
if your clone gives you a
blowy clone gives you
a blowy is that masturbation is that the
is that the question
is it's good is it uh wrong or right
is it do you think that's a good way is
it so are we asking if it's moral
[Music]
um you need to be more specific yeah
what's a good question we need to drill
in you f yourself
i think there's two questions here
if you have an exact clone of yourself
that is you and has your personality and
everything is it masturbation to
do something sexual with it
and then there's another question of is
it right or wrong to do that
so what i think what i'm interested is
do you think it's
well clearly it's weird right so so
what's the question
what is the question because obviously
it's like wrong right it's weird like if
you're like yeah we [ __ ] each other is
my clone we have sex
everyone would be like that's weird dude
yeah weirdo yeah exactly but the
question is
does it qualify as incest maybe that's
the question is that a good question
thank you uh van
not surprised he has a an interest in
this conversation yeah yeah
well how about this
why don't we just incest or wincest why
don't we just ask love
why
oh love damn you about to make me act up
fool
you about to make me act up son
look how beautiful
between
how about incest or wincest
no
how about is it incest or masturbation
incest
or masturbation
okay yeah that's good throughout the
pool yeah let's do this
if you have sex with your clone is it
incest but incest is like a sibling this
is you well it's the same thing really
as if this island boys had sex
this is why i asked about the matrix
style personality transfer because it is
different because though genetically
they may be genetic twins they are
they have their own lived experiences
they're in their independent beings
whereas if this clone is genuinely like
a carbon carbon it's an independent
being
but it but at the time of the cloning
like they're the same it's a it's a
diver like exactly yeah and then they're
matching right it's a branch off yeah so
if it's like shortly after that you can
assume i mean the lived experience is
practically the same
other than you know the few hours
they've lived they've lived together for
like 10 years and they do it every night
so this isn't something that just
happened
that changed yeah
this is a this is something that they
that's a habit that they like to do
every evening
you know it's like you playing with your
ear right yeah it's just like that it's
comfortable yeah yeah i get you
all right do we have a poll uh i'll put
it up right now so if you have sex with
your uh clone is it incest
or masturbation here we go let's ask the
community
by the way our um our guests matt and
dad are in the waiting room maybe we
could ask them to weigh in on this as
well
um
sure yeah just come out of the gate with
that well let's just wrap this up let's
just wrap this up
there's a there's a fair amount of
people 33 who think it's masturbation
well let's wait and see some
more votes here
because matt what masturbation implies
is that there's nothing wrong with it
because we all jerk off and there's and
we all know that that's like a normal
body
effectively we've asked the morality
question because you know we condemn
incest but we accept and and praise even
masturbation in most cases some people i
say no not you
that gets my dick hard
i say no
you can't masturbate
okay
i'm not gonna ask for elaboration
yo this is real 43 said masturbation
it appears to be real this is almost a
50 50. you'll want to [ __ ] yourself so
bad
it's a bad pull
bad pull
well yeah dude cause it's either
[ __ ] you love no it's wait what's the
wrong what's wrong with this pool love
he's saying because there's no choice
that you wouldn't even either because
it's not well if you're not going to do
it you don't vote
right my [ __ ] dick i think
keemstar said to himself
well this is very interesting okay
if this ever happens we need to invent a
new word that's what i'm saying
self-resist
yeah self-cyst that's what it is oh i
see what about you have the whole orgy
with like 20 of yourself because in the
future
[ __ ] so
yo we need to [ __ ] self orgy just
hundreds of myself just [ __ ]
everywhere i mean you you'd know what
you'd like
you know
you know what feels good to you that's
just too gnarly
no
you wouldn't be down for a self orgy
no
no no
wait you really you asking yeah me
neither
are you serious you would be no i don't
want to [ __ ] my i was yeah so there you
go i just thought the image is funny
well it's a funny image i'm repulsed by
myself okay got it got it
please
please the one-on-one makes more sense
you're just getting off real fast but
like a whole orgy that's just
all right well i feel like we got to
something i don't know what it is but i
mean it's a pretty closely split poll
that has that does surprise me 55 45 i
feel like this is uh
we've learned something here today
didn't we folks i'm gonna come
did we learn something i don't
yeah i'm not sure i did i'm gonna have
to reflect on this
yeah yeah okay the the percentages are
staying pretty steady so i'm gonna close
the poll well thank you guys all for
participating in this i feel like
that could be studied i don't know it
means i feel like that's scientifically
significant personally
but uh let's bring out
we have the dad who we all love we spoke
to when idubbbz was on
and his opponent matt watson of
supermega
they're both on the line
now dad talked a lot of smack about matt
and i feel like it's only fair to let
matt uh respond to dad smacks huh right
all right i'm gonna let him in right now
so stand by all
there righty go
just a little back story
um
here they are standing next to each
other now hold the phone i thought
okay so matt does seem significantly
taller than dad he is
now matt dad is doing a very dad thing
his camera is oriented the incorrect way
that may be part of the character
now matt
how tall are you
uh i'm seven six
okay that's pretty tall wow that's mom
i'm six two six two and dad how tall are
you wait six two like zach actually six
two
i said six three and i'm actually six
two oh okay okay so i'm like slightly
over six two i'm like six two in in like
a quarter but when you get into that
territory where
you add like just a little bit it sounds
like you're like a seven year old that
says like oh i'm seven and and three
quarters trying to sound older so yeah
just leave it at six two if you're if
you're short you get you got to let the
guys if you're short you round up that's
you know
you just take that for what dad how tall
are you
six feet
oh that's quite tall taller that's not
what you told me actually when you were
at my office you said that i i knew what
you were i knew what you were doing a
second ago there when you're saying it's
like a seventh grader rounding up
well i was giving you a chance to see if
you were going to do it now did he do
that
i walked into it on purpose so when dad
had all of his hair he was six feet now
i'm 5 11 and three quarters and it
sounds annoying to say that it's like oh
i'm grasping for every millimeter so i
just say what the doctor said was okay
to say is six feet the doctor cleared
the six foot matt what is your response
to that
uh
you know what if
i'll let him have it you know because at
that point it's so close like you don't
want to say your 511 like if you're
talking to someone at a bar and you're
you know you're like trying to you know
you know talk to to it to a nice lady
if you say oh i'm i'm i'm five eleven
and three quarters you know that doesn't
sound very cool six foot is is is
where it's at it's better it sounds
safer to round up it is closer to the
six i should just round up but
technically you're lying uh so i mean
that says a little bit about your
honesty but now now he has called you
out for lying dad what do we think
you're you're shaving off a quarter of
an inch there
and uh that is technically not it's in a
lie by omission so
i i don't consider it lying i consider
it building the mystery
all righty okay
yeah so matt you
matt thank you for calling it's nice to
talk with you of super mega
nice to meet you
so dad was talking a lot of smack about
you yeah he was saying you're a drug
addict a crackhead skinny
and um i obviously think it's only fair
that you respond so um do you do drugs
matt
well two of those three things are true
um
yes uh
who doesn't enjoy a little crack from
time to time sure i've tried crap once
yeah and don't knock it till you try it
you know i tried to get dad to try a
little bit when he was at a
super megaplex and he politely declined
you live in a drug den it's not a super
megaplex it's a sad plex it is okay
okay i mean it's uh
beauty is in the eye of the beholder you
know so
if that's your opinion
you must be blind
we uh do have a significant number of uh
crack pipes around our office because
fans fans mail them into us
and uh they're they're nice they're nice
it's like nice glassware so is there any
gag that that you smoke crack but it
sounds like it may or may not be a gag
um
i i do not actually smoke crack cocaine
uh
at least not at this point in my life i
haven't gotten there yet but uh we we
posted a video um
where it started out where it looked
like we were smoking crack um
because we like uh you know we had like
a blow torch i put some like some large
you know rocks of salt in the pipe uh i
used a vape to kind of get the effect
going and uh youtube took the video down
within like an hour yeah that makes
sense
so we had to re-upload it but we we
pixelated the crack pipes out and that
worked
yeah it worked well we're using a real
crack pipe because i can i can see that
i guess um
yes it was a real crack bite but what is
a crack pipe it's just like a cylinder
right it's like a it's like a little
tube with with a
like a
a ball that you put the crack into okay
i actually have i have done crack once
like so i might be more street than you
guys yeah i did crack one time what
yeah just once just to see what it was
like
i mean i've told this story before
um
i
was with some friends who were smoke who
were doing crack
and i just gave it a shot casual friday
night hangout that was it i just tried
it one time you know
just a rock or two of crack i didn't
feel anything though dad and uh
i didn't have it was dad
dad for the first time
five years ago the first time i had
alcohol i feel like a baby yeah too
compared to you guys
same thing don't do crack by the way
guys just for the record just to be
clear on that one we do not
but um you know for now no crack for me
thanks
no
well i have an open door policy for you
both
oh okay well no but don't do crack guys
the my friends who are smoking crack
they're dead now
i'm just kidding but they're they're not
their lives are a [ __ ] disaster okay
just saying
no crack endorsement here all right so
so what other charges did you lay
against matt uh dad
i was just saying how unbelievably
unhealthy he is how unphysically inept
he is the drugs he just stops smoking
vaping doing drugs drinking heavily he
has a trash
barrel filled with lighters from
billions of cigarettes usually those are
those lighters have never been used
are you sure those aren't old
unused ones i promise uh we sold
lighters for our 420 drop and um
we poured like six boxes of them into
like a halloween cauldron that you get
candy out of so when people come to our
office they can grab a handful and i
realized like it's been next to my desk
for six months and i i didn't realize
i'm essentially just sitting next to a
bomb like
just one little part
yeah
okay well
they're not used they're not used now
matt do you think you're possibly going
to be beating dad he's been training
hard he's obviously got a six-pack which
he likes to show off frequently
yeah uh
i think it's out of the question ethan
that i'm going to beat that you're a lot
taller
yeah and my reach is
you know extraordinarily longer
and uh that's
that's uh that's a pretty big deal when
it comes to boxing not if i'm in that
pocket where i like to hang hey if you
come hang in my pocket man that's gonna
happen i'll snuggle up all around all
the rounds what's gonna happen matt if
he hangs in your pocket i'll snuggle
with him you know i'll i'll i'll go i'll
i'll go right back in you know i'll be
in there in that pocket with him and i'm
not going to let him have the fun he
wants to have
did i party hard and i just literally
got out of here you drank alcohol for
the first time five years ago
that's right i party hard
in the way that i will be on this earth
the longest
holy [ __ ] i will continue partying can
matt see this
uh dan
oh damn damn i can i can pull up the
the stream let me see that is scary dude
he got a physique
dude i mean dad you wanna you wanna say
you're gonna come in my pocket but i'm
already out of pocket and that's uh
in case you don't know what that means
that's like a it's like a gen z uh
you know terminology for for going a
little crazy being wild
yeah yeah yeah i've heard i heard it
hurt before
yeah yeah i think he's saying you're
fully
i believe he's different i believe he's
accused of being old dad
oh yeah well so hey dad bought here i've
only been alive for three years i was
built modeled after a 41 year old man so
appearances are deceiving i am fresh out
of the factory
you see i've seen a lot of glamour
muscles in these pictures of you dad
those are power i don't think that's
glamour muscle man i got to say i think
that's real
because you i do even exercise matt
that's just pure or i mean uh dad that's
just pure sorry i didn't mean that oh me
yeah
you even exercise dad this looks like
pure muscle
from dancing [ __ ]
the picture in the middle no exercise
the picture on the left and right was
after
uh a month and a half of exercise
oh boy that was that was the beginning
of the pandemic from what i just watched
dragon uh a
demon slayer
every night and i look exercise all
while watching it now
you know i'll say there there's no
question that the you know the
testosterone is it's a bit more
prevalent in your bald people have a lot
of testosterone i know i know uh
testosterone yeah like makes you lose
your hair
um so i mean say say what you will about
that so hey it looks like you're
actually if i look close looks like
you're getting a little stronger then
yeah yeah maybe i've been uh i thank you
you know i'm very self-conscious about
my hairline bleaching the hair wishing
the hair is a way to hide that
that's that's actually why i did it
because when i'm in the ring i don't
want people to
you know it's closer to the skin tone so
matt are you willing to fall do the same
thing matt are you willing to pull back
your hair and let us see the hairline
because dad is has it all on display
he's obviously not hiding anything well
but not by choice for him
so
yeah i'll uh
i think nature's intentions
hairline reveal okay um
see let's see
oh that's not bad yeah that's that's
really not that bad
thank you it's a distinguished airline
you got nothing to worry about sorry
distinguish sounds like that's still
kind of that sounds like a veiled like
no it's a distinguished hairline no it's
good it's you got a bruce willis
hairline it's nice
i've been told by many women
no i think it's a nice hair i'm just
saying listen as the hairline king
i feel qualified to say and i'm sorry
dad i'm going to take i think matt's got
a nice haircut
here's what here's what uh i was told by
a friend was that like if you can make
it through i think 23 or 24 without any
signs of hair loss you're you're good
but i don't know who that is
completely false
okay
not at all you can if i had a friend
that lost it at 18 i had a friend that
just started losing it at 40.
when you when you first started uh
bombing well well when
when nathan sorry when when nathan first
started
nathan started losing his hair at 21.
oh okay okay yeah that's like right away
goddamn
i
bleach is good for the scalp and it and
it helps the hair grow actually a lot of
people it actually fries the hair and
makes it go faster
all right well listen so
uh matt have you been training hard um
i'm just trying to calculate the odds
here have you been training a lot i have
been yes actually yeah i'm the
healthiest i've ever been right now and
the heaviest as well
i i've been training i do five days a
week oh well i know it's not it's not
it's not it's not dad's seven days a
week um
but uh i have one day off i have one day
off oh okay okay like okay yeah i've
been i've been training um going pretty
hard uh i don't want to give away too
much because i feel like if i give away
too much then i'm going to let dad in on
he's going to know exactly what to do
yeah i don't want to know i like the
mystery i'd rather not know
it seems to me and then i'll cover my
ear
uh matt
you are seems to be like mid-20s do i
have that right
yes yes okay i'm 26. so and then dad is
41 so that's obviously a huge that that
i mean that's a huge age i think i'm the
oldest fighter yeah i think matt's the
youngest and i think i'm the oldest on
the card that's an interesting matchup
also on the card we haven't mentioned
this we're the first fight
yeah
oh that means people are least excited
for your fight i believe i know i know
that's why we're bringing the hype but
that's in [ __ ] because i feel like
um i feel like i i can't wait to watch
you guys fight i think that i feel
i read every comment on every video ever
and i think we have a lot of hype on us
we do
i think we have
people are talking about us idubbbz uh
and eager raptor
and harley is all i'm seeing is those
excuse me
i mean everyone's been talking about
what i'm seeing
i'm hard of me
maybe maybe
obviously i don't remember everyone
everyone who's on the card but i focus
obviously see when my name is mentioned
so
i've seen a lot of it i was gonna say i
think me and brett and then dad and matt
have the most different like body types
in terms of matchups but i gotta say i'm
thankful for brett because he's not
taunting me the way dad is taunting dad
yeah dad is really going for the throat
of matt is he getting in your head at
all matt
no absolutely not
you know were you guys friends before
all this i i think to get in my head
he'd have to actually have some good
zingers and be funny um
but the stuff he's saying is just you
know i've heard about i'm not trying to
be funny i'm just being realistic i'm
not trying to be funny
yeah and yes we were friends before matt
became an actual scumbag on his podcast
and made a low blow and now we're not
friends anymore so it seems that this
competition has gotten between what was
it was a good friendship but
um it was an excellent friendship matt
say something nice about dad
um
i
i think that uh i like your tie
wow
wow he i think he's lying dad
i think so too i don't believe anything
he's saying okay i'll give you a real
compliment um
i i have been a fan of you since i was
in high school
and and i've always admired your dancing
abilities
uh and i don't like the tie actually
that was a lie
i don't think i don't like the colors on
it i think
brown orange and white is kind of tacky
when put together and yellow that makes
it even worse
that's [ __ ] and piss okay it's
respectable i did ask for a compliment
but that took kind of a left turn there
with the [ __ ] and pissed he is right i
mean brown yellow that is and white i
mean well white it does it is
reminiscent of a public toilet dad say
something nice about matt if you would
please
um i like that you're actually trying
even though this is the hardest thing
you've ever done and you shouldn't be
doing something like this but you are
still trying
thank you yeah i really appreciate that
this is the hardest thing i've ever done
and i like i like your music it's not as
good as mine but i do like your music i
understand no thank you i uh i love your
music and i remember when i was in like
ninth grade i always watched all your
videos with my friends well thank you
thank you i watched nathan's videos not
not yours but i watched nathan's videos
the dancing videos it inspired me to
to become a dancer and now i'm almost as
good as you thank you wait are you are
you going are you in the ring are you
gonna pull any moves out are you gonna
try to
my victory dance will definitely be
happening i'll do that
in the ring now go ahead and matt and
then matt if you would say something
mean about that just to balance it out
um
i really don't like that tie man back to
the tie
no um
you're a little too old to be doing this
i think um
[Laughter]
you know like this is something you
should be doing in your 20s
right uh
but
luckily my body is still in its 20s and
yours is in
pre pre-mortem if we're being fully
honest
i think our body uh ages like might be
pretty close
okay
i'll give you that all right and dad if
you could say something just vicious
about the
matt
i mean where do i start the this is the
worst worst decision you've ever made
your nose will break again your body he
i'm just telling facts it might have
been being mean his toes are busted he
can't balance my toes
they're [ __ ] up nasal problem he has
uh
horrible lungs he has no stamina and he
is more personal with my medical history
sorry i just stating the facts you know
i know it all
you know
no i have bunions really bad like a like
an old [ __ ] lady and um it makes my
my first two crows like cross over each
other like
like this so it all the bones
my feet are played
yeah i have a i have like orthopedics um
and i'm hoping they'll let me use them
in the match i don't know why they
wouldn't but i could see last minute
they're like no this is against you know
boxing commission guidelines so what is
how you're screwed man you're screwed i
am screwed if i can't wear those
orthopedics i'll be honest so what is it
i need my special shoes
so wait what does these orthopedic shoes
do for you
uh
so i have these inserts where it like
gives me more
like support under my foot because when
i step like all the weight is
distributed wrong and then like my foot
kind of like twists a little bit so it
gives me support but i also have these
like splints that i wear that look like
from like the 1500s where it forcefully
takes my big toe and like
breaks it into position
and it hurts like hell dad is loving
this
i mean i
i will feel bad if it i also i don't
people think it's set up because if i
knock him out right away i want people
like oh this is rake but i'm planning on
knocking you out
so
okay
well i mean we have similar plans and uh
if that's your plan then i don't admire
that
how do you plan on knocking me out
honestly like
by punching you
but yeah i need more than that i take
punches i do ten rounds three minutes
non-stop
i did fourteen times
how many fourteen
[Laughter]
i believe dad what was the first thing
you said before you guys started really
so
uh what i've been doing sparring is uh
we'll go we worked we started doing a
six and then eight and now ten rounds
that's what i'm boring three minutes 45
seconds rest because that seems like a
lot
that's the real deal
but matt you say you do that too
uh
yeah so
here's where i embarrass myself i've
been doing those drugs for that long
i've been i do drugs for a lot longer
than that
i i was doing uh i'm doing the two
minute rounds but i'm going like i'm i'm
basically emulating what the match is
going to be but i just i go about 14.
14 rounds
that's a lot that seems that seems
intense it's exhausting it's very that
seems like it's not fun
yeah we started that a while ago we did
we emulate the match now we're going
above and beyond to guarantee i won't
blow out and i will be at a punch the
whole time oh yeah goodness this week
we're we're we're stepping it up too now
it's so close like it keeps like
surprising me i'm like [ __ ] yeah it's
coming up eh three weeks 18 days 18 days
i know i can't speak for you guys but
amy can't wait for this to be over he's
just waiting he can't [ __ ] wait same
here the madness i cannot wait it's
gonna be like the second i step out of
that ring uh with my trophy i'm gonna
have the biggest sigh of relief and i'll
be like oh my god it's done yeah
well will you guys feel better will you
guys feel bad if the other one has to
get taken away on a gurney
no i'm i'm bringing the body back with
his name on it on it actually
no joke dude i haven't made it here's
what i'm gonna say
i feel like you're
the fight you're not going to kill me
that's obvious but i but i feel like
you're willing my death into existence
after the fight because like you're
selling shirts with my headstone on it
now hold on we have this photo of this
no that's actually i actually don't know
ethan there's much more than just shirts
so can i can i say really quick uh shout
out to ren who it's her birthday she's
from england she says you're eating the
beans and toasts wrong and altoid yoda
they make my merch because of ren and
yoda why am i eating beans and toast
wrong everybody keeps having friends
wait what did i do
ren said because you can't have it when
it's like reheated or like old you
should only eat it when it's fresh it
was fresh we just got it this morning
okay she she was watching i mean we did
reheat it to be fair yeah that's what
she didn't like she's like it's only
good when it's not does she really think
i would have liked it
if it was fresh i don't know
all right thank you for the note well
received but yeah randy and yoda made
this merch happen uh and it's the best
merch i've ever sold matt's headstone
so thank you so this is a headstone with
matt watson on it now matt do you find
this in poor taste
uh yeah i do um because if if i were to
have an untimely passing uh everyone
that bought that merch would be like
it'll go up in price so your your
concern matt is that if you have an
untimely death not in the ring but let's
say you're in the ring maybe you
overdose on crack or something late a
few years later you actually can't
overdose on crack is that right
that can't be true
no that's an overdose on crack
a lot of people die from crack right
uh yeah you must be gonna die from crack
yeah i'm just goofing about the crack
okay no crack i'm cracking a couple
jokes
uh but yeah i if i actually do like
let's just say later this year i'm in a
horrible car accident i mean everyone
that bought that merch is going to feel
a little awkward
your response to that dad
i think it'll do it's a perfect way for
us to remember you it's like who's
actually go to the funeral if i if i
pass uh
young i want you to come to my funeral
and i i want you to wear that shirt
i will will you really i will wear the
underwear so i have the underwear let me
scroll down the mouse i'll bring a mouse
pad can i can i get your word on that
hundred percent i swear now moving on
you're also selling this image with the
gravestone on underwear now dad no
offense but i'm not quite sure who's
going to buy this
i've already sold a ton you've sold a
ton of the underwear with matt watson
yes all of it and are you i'm i'm
i'm wearing that to weigh in i made that
so i can wear it to the weigh-in oh okay
that makes sense and then is there
anything you're trying to say with
putting it on your butt
well he's
i mean he's he is an ass so
there's that
okay we're selling it with underwear
we're selling it on chef kurt a chef
uh an apron
all walks of life love to enjoy matt's
death a pillow for
i think you might be taking this a
little too far dad no that's so fast
well you know
he he didn't ask me for permission
before using my likeness to we don't
know what he's not giving me he's not
even giving me a cut of it
there's another matt watson who knows
it's you i don't i didn't say who
several not watching i i know but
you know i feel like in court i could
argue pretty easily
you know yeah i i made sure i was clear
there's so many matt watsons if i wasn't
training so hard right now and all my
time was consumed by it i would i would
be filing a lawsuit but uh
i'm i'm not doing that yet after the
fight i will be doing that though
you got enough of those you're you're
good how would you react if like just
i heard you were in a lawsuit but i
guess you can't talk about it matt but
brothers
the real [ __ ]
i've got four so shout out my brother
damn try i'm trying to wrap them up like
that
you know you know you're successful when
you got them exactly exactly the more
lost i don't have any
how would you even keep up with that
you don't
he doesn't even know it's just the
lawyers just handling it probably yeah
yeah i saw he got held in contempt of
court today
trump yeah oh no
i was just celebrating him getting back
on twitter because elon musk i have an
update about that but we'll get to that
later
oh well just tell me no
he trump declared that even if elon buys
twitter he will not be returning and he
will continue to be using his own
platform he has never tweeted on it
trump what are you doing
that's good news i mean i think he's
lying he's definitely coming back
because bam wouldn't lie
right that's true
that's true he has a platform called
truth social how could he lie i know
that's what i've been promoting the
fight on the most
that's why no one knows about it okay
nathan i mean dad okay okay okay well a
little confusing well
uh matt are you gonna make some dad
merch or something or are you just
taking the high road on this
well i think it'll be confusing because
he already has a weird relationship with
his dad if you're a supermega fan and
people were i got a lot of gross
comments from his fans because
matt's got an interesting song called i
love my dad
uh yeah i think my name is dale now
yeah uh that's my my father he's a he's
a great man um and i did make a song
about having sex with my dad uh
which he uh
was not very pleased about when he heard
it i can imagine sure yeah well i didn't
tell him about the song but uh okay also
this song is not about dale it's not
about my father it's it's more from like
a
like like a perspective from just like
it's not from from matt watson's
perspective you know
you know a lot of people write music and
you know it's not what they sing about
it's not actually them it's more of like
a general you know
like person a story a universal
experience exactly like wanting to [ __ ]
your dad yeah okay let's do a poll now
let's take it to the poll okay guys we
have dad versus
matt
here
and i'm wondering matt of super mega who
what do the audience think is going his
favor to win this fight
so
i'd like to get some feedback and then
get your comments on that
um so the question is who's going to win
the fight yeah who do who's favored to
win the fight who do they think is going
to win he's going to win the fight matt
or dad okay
um to i have a
new music video premiering at five today
that shows a preview matt's in it shows
a preview of what's going to happen
in our fight
songs called obliterate it gives you a
little bit of a hint
hold on i have to go vote for myself
real quick
obliterate get your votes in get your
votes and people all right so
for me i can't vote so someone vote for
me
well you won't need anyone to vote for
you because at this moment there's 75
uh favoring dad to be victorious
oh wow seventy-five percent what the
hell i i'm not discrediting that anyone
you never know what's gonna happen i am
taking this very seriously because i do
think matt might hurt me so
i'm preparing for that here's
76 yeah i just went up it's actually 76
now
daddy you know what even if you guys
don't vote for me i still you know i
appreciate
um
the support
which i know you all have well i know
everyone in the chat supports me you
know it might not be a popular opinion
but
i appreciate it
well there you have it guys i
i can't believe they placed you first
there's got to be let me look at this
roster there's got to be a work a less
compelling fight
there is they're doing uh like a pro
fight before that's not actually less
compelling put the pros in front nobody
cares about the pro are these are they
first the pros
okay good good good oh okay our buddy
justin organized the event told me that
you got to love the pros they're like
they spent their whole life practicing
and getting prepared and
they're just like
[ __ ] these guys
see i think i'm happy to go and watch
our fight because it's the first fight i
feel like a lot of people would tune in
to the beginning i i actually agree i
feel like you got to come out of the
gate strong you know yeah i i think matt
and i are doing i think that's not how
we're in the
hype i'm actually surprised at uh
how
pretty much no one else is is beefing
over over the fight yeah there's a lot
just a lot of sweethearts i've noticed
everyone here is pretty respectful kings
which is nice and refreshing
um
keemstar
is uh
q star is just not getting his way this
time i saw you tweeting at keemstar matt
do you have a pr do you have a
preference with keemstar uh
alive or dead what's your preference
oh my god
you don't have to answer that
i'm going to respectfully decline to
answer that i will say understandable
understandable i appreciate both you
guys i heard your podcast where you guys
were defending me and my wife uh when it
came to the keemstar situation so thank
you guys that was one thing you guys are
going to do
i tried to defend well see i i agree
with keemstar on most points but
that one i would i couldn't that was too
funny i appreciate it yeah that one's
that's where it went too far
i tried to defend uh to his face or on
the call with him that day yeah i tried
to be like very rational i was like but
come on i mean like he does know what
he's doing when he does that he was like
what no i no it was just a picture of
you know a witch like it had nothing to
do like i think if he was
if he was honest like no one would be
like you guys he would just own it be
like yeah yeah i'm calling him a witch
like that's what i do but like he denies
it which makes it worse
is that he's too stupid to understand
the joke basically if he says he didn't
know what he's doing then he's like they
they think the ultimate uh comedy is to
be like they called their own wives a
witch they're a [ __ ] idiot
but there you have it okay well guys
the home stretch is here it is keep
training hard matt prove them wrong
that's going to and dad send him home in
a body bag
i got it i just want you to give it your
best i'm not gonna miss that fight i'll
tell you what are you going anywhere
thank you thank you
i want to but
i'm afraid of
i'm trying to make it work but i don't
know i'd love to see it i'm trying to
set up
i'm trying to set up an after party
after the fight after it's all done or
matt and i want to play
playing a club completely conflict
we're gonna have to do it together matt
we're having a super mega pool party at
an airbnb
we need to perform matt for the fans
after you guys want to do like a musical
collab
i i want a dj at a club
i actually would love to do that if you
still want to do a show like i do you
just you got to just you know do it with
no head so
yeah i'll see you know figure that out
hey well that's that's kind of nathan
that's kind of nathan's style there's no
head
that's a joke referring to oral sex
right like no head oh oh i was like wait
i don't i didn't get that one at all
sometimes my comedy's a little bit too
high brow and it takes people a second
to uh yeah do not feel bad
a little bottom of the barrel in my
opinion was that the joe a dead do not
do not give him dad he's saying i don't
get it receive it
is that true yeah oral sex is that true
well i i am partly i am have been alone
for a long time but i don't need it
because i have my little friends here i
got so are you saying now that your dog
gives you yeah
because that's what it came off
peanut butter do you have
dad do you how much peanut butter do you
have in your house oh it's got a lot of
empty jars
oh my god i saw that episode with that
guy i was like
that's that's demented
well we learned even more unfortunately
about him and that's nothing compared to
the [ __ ] we learned about him after the
episode
[Laughter]
oh a dog is smoking a little cigarette
that's his tooth this is frankie tooth
so he's got like a little a little
little j in his mouth
yeah he's got a funky underbody how old
is he
14. oh what a little what a legend i
love him so much
give him a shout out frankie truth on
instagram you're going to check him out
oh he has an instagram protect him
forever
yeah we're going down to l.a i'm at the
airport right now in the parking lot
we're going to go down to lla in a
couple hours
visit a couple places with him god i
love you guys
uh
i don't know if you're at the photo
shoot i might see you there oh you're
doing promo for the fight
yeah
i'll be there good oh i'm taking you
involved
they're doing everyone separately the
photographer is actually coming here for
me oh see
avie's getting some vip treatment he
says they're coming to the studio
they're not coming tomorrow wow that's
nice i i think
you have to be one of the later fights
for the photographer
you guys hear that
i'm just playing you know where they
placed uab no did they make it official
i don't know
i think i i saw the list i think you're
uh i i want to say like sixth
fifth or sixth
that's pretty low down there maybe
that's
good around the middle i think or in the
middle i mean in middle a b
are you confident that you're gonna
defeat him uh in all honesty i don't
know i have no clue i've learned that
with sparring because like one day i
think i'm the best fighter alive next
day i feel like i don't know anything so
honestly yeah it just comes down to the
fight itself i guess because it's like i
uh if we're speaking truthfully
please don't
okay no i'm just kidding
i'm going to win i'm going to kick
dad's ass no plea i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding guys and then that that
tells us the truth right there then i do
want to hear you speak truthfully yeah
are you sure yeah because uh i'm not
afraid to say it i say i say it how it
is yeah please do i wanna hear it
um
it's it's obvious that the dad has
a lot more
uh muscle
a lot more stamina
um i mean he's a dancer for christ's
sake right
the things you need to box yeah it's
non-stop cardio what he got right and
and you know
you had that long before this match so
uh i've been doing my best to to to hone
it in but for being realistic you know
you're gonna be better in those skills
and you've also been boxing for much
longer than me
uh
so you're a more skilled
uh athlete
when it comes down to it but dad is
loving this
but
what else is there
do you know what matt i don't know dad
we got
you don't even know my secret weapon yet
you don't have a knife in your gloves do
you yeah
nope
i'm speaking of gloves here they are
right here this is the last thing you'll
see matt
wait what is that symbol
it's a peanut that's the dad logo it's
like a little chip it does look like a
little no it does a little micro penis
it showed yeah
all right ethan you want round two come
on keep talking no hey i didn't
volunteer for that i don't want i don't
want that heat smoke it's like the nasa
logo but it says dad it stands for
distant aerospace destinations you gotta
watch the series unlike youtube i see it
does say dad it also does look like a
small penis i think matt pointed out oh
right
if it wasn't
if it might be like going all the way
over the other side of the glove
that's disgusting why would you talk
about your your penis that way on on a
public podcast when they built dad
bought they built him right
well that dick is big we've established
that it's massive but are you saying
that if are you saying that small
penises are wrong then
i'm not saying they're wrong it's just
that's what you wrote it's just what it
is you said when they built him they
built him right implying that
interesting
wow
small
[Music]
your little penis ethan is good for you
wow
i'm sorry about him ethan um no this is
unprofessional this this is uh this has
gone too far i'm really sorry about him
i'm gonna throw a a real hard one in the
ring for you thanks bro but throw yeah
you got to bring i'll make a a dead body
bag with the small penis rest in peace
or something this small penis right
there's a penis i'll bite it off in the
ring it's like
[ __ ]
you know oh so now what do you guys
think about a bee versus hyundai give me
the honest take here
um
i mean hunter is pretty big but i've i
have heard that ab has been training
pretty hard yeah yeah i sparred with ian
the other day uh
and he he was telling me how you've been
training really hard he has been yeah
wait isn't your uh
i i heard through the grapevine that
your your coach is like
a real big badass he definitely is he
killed someone in the ring yeah okay i
didn't know if i was like that's that's
what i heard yeah and i found out
recently that it was a sparring match it
wasn't even an actual match bro that is
that's
wow that's crazy
that's really crazy yeah so amy's being
coached by someone who killed one of his
opponents in the ring
and i heard av well you know i thought
sensitive i didn't want to joke about it
right
i mean yeah i mean he's coming wednesday
so i'm sure that will go over really
well please don't so you killed a guy
huh well he's his coach is coming on the
show i'm gonna talk to him i gotta ask
him about it
i'll be sensitive though
i think ab will win i've been saying it
for a while i do too
uh i've five bucks i have nothing
against 10 dollar fund
i'm sure is cool oh thank you guys but
i've i've barred with like more muscular
guys and they can't throw as many
punches as i am when i'm in the ring
with them so if i know everyone's
different so maybe hyundai can
constantly bring it but
i think it kind of you benefit a little
bit being the smaller no are you is that
are you speaking in favor of matt
because clearly he's not as muscley as
you maybe he's gonna have more endurance
oh we need to have some muscle
to start you know
got it i'm not appreciating this
dad
i mean dude
matt
that's the number one rule no one do not
call me daddy no no no is it what about
you
is that hate
dude you tell people not to do something
they're gonna do it yeah you better
start making daddy merch for you
daddy chill
there's a video on matt's channel or
super mega where it's like he's working
out and you can see his body like a
hundred percent what that was like
that's like three years ago and it's not
real working out
you were lifting weights
that is true i guess that's true matt
can we get a saw you two weeks ago you
look the same
mac can we get an ab reveal perhaps
sure
um no pressure you don't have to but
let's just put that in his place
well it's nothing like
it's nothing like his but
hey look at tyson fury he's the champ
what do we think about that
now dad can we see the abs kind of
underwhelming
there's a lot there though
you know it's okay
dad can we get the abs let's see
impromptu abs someone's gonna be walking
by this dude in his parking lot just
like some old creepy looking
showing his abs off to someone on the
phone
oh [ __ ] bro
yeah
okay
dad's always got those abs ready i just
i use the uh
zoom filters
but i mean
oh is that what that was dad
have you have you actually listened to
the song i made about um
fornicating with my father i've listened
to all your songs i was a fan i went to
your last live show and you ruined it
when i came on your podcast so yes i've
heard it
listen man
it's nothing personal it's just business
yeah well
that thought had a good beat it was
catchy unfortunately because it kept me
listening to this hor those lyrics are
disgusting yeah that's the thing a lot
of people actually like the song but
they're like i can't listen to this over
and over because i mean it's not as good
as my diss track on you which also i'm
about to ratio matt everyone matt made a
diss track on me and my response is
about to surpass his in views well see i
haven't been constantly promoting mine
well because i'm the best youtuber man
you gotta go you gotta buy true youtube
you gotta do it all 24 7. i don't stop
dad can't be stopped
well guys i gotta say
i'm very excited about your guys's fight
genuinely we have matt watson of super
mega
who is going up against dad of dad right
dad of dad
i'm super excited what can i say i'm
very excited for the event it's almost
sold out right abby the the yeah what
this is exciting you guys the creator
guys i'm very excited for it yeah
biggest day of my life honestly thank
you idubbbz anissa i can't thank you
enough i'm i'm so pumped um
baby all the way are you willing to help
me pay for uh surgery afterwards because
you know about my nose you told me about
this before and i think this was i was
talking about that i would talk to items
about that one yeah they have the nose
job groupons wait yeah yeah they have a
group on nose jobs yeah they do
what the [ __ ] yeah
so basically my nose i had a really
deviated septum and i couldn't breathe
out of the right nostril so i got uh
last year i got i got a septoplasty oh
me too and when i it's amazing now i can
i can breathe it changed my life but now
um
i'm scared of getting hit because when i
went for a follow-up appointment the
doctor's like now the one thing uh that
you don't want to happen is you don't
want to get hit in the nose ever oh my
god it's just going to break
and i was like
you have a glass nose i do i have a
glass nose so are you going to be going
into expensive surgery are you going for
his nose dad as a strategy
so this is the thing like when i first
started sparring i did feel a little
weird and guilty and i started aiming
for people's foreheads because i felt
bad about punching the nose
used to it i i genuinely was doing that
and my coach was like what are you doing
i was like i just feel kind of weird
about punching my face you just punch
him in the face so i'm hoping that
instinct doesn't kick in and i hate that
man even told me about this because now
i feel bad
i'm not playing mind games it's just the
truth you are though unfortunately and
you know if you're going for the nose
you know you're you're more so going for
my wallet than
my nose because
it's expensive and health insurance
sucks ass it covers almost nothing
they're like that's elective they're
like breathing is elective
also i didn't know that uh
you get like a separate bill for
anesthesia so like after i paid off my
surgery i was like [ __ ] done with that
and then i just get this letter in the
mail like two months later and it was
like you owe five thousand dollars uh
for going to sleep and i was like if i
knew i would have told him to do it when
i was awake i would have been fine with
it awake yeah the only other surgery
i've had was on my [ __ ] uh what was
that
what was that surgery
i actually a lot of people think it's a
bit um
because everyone thinks like everything
anytime something serious happens people
think we're joking like when uh matt
what happened to your [ __ ] people
thought that it was uh a bit of my
[ __ ] um
i just i wanted it to be a little more
cute
oh okay like anal reconstruction surgery
yeah it is smooth and it is it is pink
what no what was it looking like before
i mean it was still smooth and pink but
you know it didn't it didn't have that
like
it didn't if the light hits you just
right yeah it looks good no but i had a
i
never surgery inside of my [ __ ] uh
i'm not afraid to say it
you know a boy had some hemorrhoids it
was awful it was that's fine the worst
that happened
yeah but i basically had surgery like
deep inside my [ __ ] and uh it was one
it was the worst week of my life
afterwards so how did you know that you
had hemorrhoids
uh cause it hurt real bad when i went
dudu okay interesting
and so you went to a doctor did they
have to stick a finger up there or how
did they find it yeah so i went to the
doctor um
and there's laws in
i guess california or just maybe
everywhere where it's like if the doctor
you know does anything uh inappropriate
like if he has to stick his finger up my
ass there has to be a witness
uh no person to make sure really
he goes on i don't want to witness yeah
i had a is that a new law a month ago
and there was no one witnessing this i
got to figure out my butt once it was no
witness
just me and elijah
oh this sucks because basically like
he's like all right just stand up and uh
drop your slacks and uh just kind of
bend over and i was like okay and they
call in a witness
and it it's it's it's the most beautiful
girl i've ever seen oh my god no way um
like we're the same age and i was like
oh my god so like i have to just like
kind of stay you should have been like
what's up girl
hey there's plenty more with this you
want to talk after this
you want to stick around after this let
me let me hit you up i asked if she
wanted to go uh for a spin with it and
give it a try but she said no
but basically yeah she just had to stand
there and and like stare at this doctor
you know
fingering my ass and it was very
humiliating
oh
i didn't know about the witness thing
that is that is interesting
you know i never heard that either one
of my doctors thought
i think you may have been violated there
matt
yeah like this is kind of uh
it's not cool man
like i uh
could i you think i could sue him for
malpractice
i think you could look into it
listen i like i said i'm trying to rack
up those lawsuits i'm trying to get to
where you act get to those big numbers
yeah i got a finger in my butt like a
long time ago in college they thought i
might have a hemorrhoid and i had to lay
on my side
and he just buttered a finger up
and he plopped it in there it wasn't
that bad actually but there was no
witness he made me like stand up and
like basically like just get down like
oh no way he did that
yeah that's what i did he bent me over a
little like he's like arch that thing
come on boy the bed that you lie on he
like bent me over
okay because i liked when he made me lay
down in the prone it seemed to go in
easier
and then i think that and i'm already in
the prone position which is the morning
position anyway so i just don't have to
move after that
yeah
well i wonder if the witness is so that
they can't you couldn't say oh he did
something sketchy i think that that's
the the reason
yeah is so there's like a third party
there that's like he didn't suck his
dick that's so interesting
yeah yeah it was very humiliating for me
okay i wonder if she still thinks about
it
not as much now she sees it all the time
but i think that this probably
you know stuck with her well dad are you
going to be giving uh matt a colonoscopy
are you going to be checking his uh
prostate on the day of the fight
if it wasn't an illegal move i would do
it but
they specifically have that in like the
rulebook
yeah
you can't go for the prostate the fish
hook
yeah i think i think
i think idubbbz got a punched in the the
rectum during his training footage i
think i remember seeing someone how did
you get to the victim like that's like
the complete opposite side of
where did i see that idubbbz in one of
his videos recently someone was punching
him in the butt
when they were training
they were just goofing around but uh
yeah well we don't we don't we don't
approve of the goofing around i don't i
don't i don't like goofing but okay so
new goofing around so matt you had a
hemorrhoid surgery they went ahead and
six hemorrhoids in my ass
yeah it was so [ __ ] cool it's
genetics like it's a it's like a genetic
thing so you have a bunch of bad genes
your parents do have the hemorrhoids
yeah we used to do family checks
together
um but basically i had like all sides of
my ass and they had to basically go in
uh
with like lasers and blades and
they actually just use regular stitches
inside your ass but did they dissolve on
their own or did they have to go take
them out yes they luckily they dissolve
okay
you know
and so and so how's your [ __ ] feeling
now much better
oh it feels great feels fantastic wow
i'm like i'm glad i got the surgery done
but i never if i knew that the recovery
process was going to be that painful i
wouldn't have done it really they only
provide me ibuprofen like 500 milligram
ibuprofen oh yeah in california it's
kind of it's kind of crazy they like
don't won't give anyone opioids you have
to but if you go like to like any
you know
like small town everybody in town is
just cruising on
[ __ ] because when i got my septoplasty
uh the recovery process was not bad at
all and they gave me vicodin and i was
like why did i not get this when i
stopped since it got all crazy and
there's been all these pr lawsuits they
stopped giving people a year ago
yeah
oh oh really yeah you're saying that he
got the septoplasty like a year ago
right because like i don't know the
septoplasty was after the ass surgery
yeah i don't know do you have like
kaiser permanente or something because
like i know i have anthem
so some big insurer groups are like
we're not giving anyone opioids unless
they're like dying because we don't want
to get sued
oh
interesting yeah i shattered my i
shattered my heel
and got surgery and they gave me vicodin
and i flushed it down to it didn't take
one whole time
dad that's why you're a [ __ ]
that's because i i know i mentally can
get through i also just don't like
taking i don't even take time i don't
take anything ever i take my vitamins
let's put it are you like one of those
weird like science christians that
christian scientists do no i just don't
i just don't unless i really need it and
i didn't really need it i genuinely
didn't think it was that bad so i just
didn't take it but i'm not against
taking medicine for i like science and i
like medicine but i just don't need it i
got my vaccines and
i don't do it unless i really well you
might be taking it after this fight
right matt
absolutely you'll be taking some tylenol
you're gonna you're gonna need a little
tylenol
the only thing i'm gonna have is i'm
finally gonna get a mai tai after six
months i'm gone i would like to have a
mai tai with you dad's gonna spiral
from that mai tai he's gonna spiral into
alcoholism and
one single my child that's all it takes
it's a gateway gateway drug all right
well uh once again matt watson who has
recovered from
a ton of hemorrhoids which we were very
happy for
thank you thank you dad
the favor by pole
what was so bad about the recovery
process i actually wanted to ask you
what it was just painful the pooping
what tell me about it well so yeah
imagine having like six open wounds
inside your [ __ ] yeah uh and then uh
when you when you [ __ ] it's
very very painful it was the [ __ ]
itself that was the [ __ ] was was was
the worst yeah but also like it was just
so painful like laying in bed like it
would just hurt and then i'd try to go
to sleep and i'd like wake myself up
because i would move and you don't
realize how many muscles are in your
[ __ ] that really just just
go off all the time on their own right
like the slightest movement like like
you wave at someone in your [ __ ]
like contracting and you felt that the
whole time yeah it was it was awful also
speaking of which you uh
i was listening before i came on and you
were talking about the thing where you
uh like push your dick inside of itself
yes
yeah that's that's classic yeah every
guy does that yeah that's standard there
you there you have it
it's standard it's something you try you
know matt are you are you circumcised
i am yeah so there you go we we've
answered the question no but i feel like
even if you
aren't circumcised you could still do it
you could i kind of agree i i i i think
there's a second layer
right you can
you can really dad do you know what
we're talking about yeah yeah that been
there done that everyone
yeah
i'm not circumcised and i can do it well
there you go there you go a lot of
knowledge uh lots of knowledge sharing
fantastic is great yeah
and also on the clone thing that's
definitely uh it's not masturbation it's
it's not it's a it's an incest situation
because because think about it this way
if 42nd president bill clinton uh had
been sucked off in the oval office by a
clone of himself
it would be a sex scandal
you know between two people it wouldn't
have been like oh he masturbated
like they would very clearly define that
as like he was had sexual relations with
himself and that's not the causation but
it's not the closest thing physically
it's just the first that came to my head
uh dad would you [ __ ] your clone yes or
no
well there's many dad bots in the
facility and
none of us
would ever go near each other so no okay
no no no i personally would you would
[ __ ] yourself not your clone dad but
myself yeah yeah i'm not i'm not one of
the good ones
one yes one no
sharply divided ethan would i [ __ ]
myself yeah hell no i mean not that i'm
not opposed to like
but i mean i'm just i'm grotesque so the
fact that anyone
i wouldn't want to put myself in that i
wouldn't want to put anyone in that
situation but uh
where does everyone else stand on that
i think they're all going to say no to
be pc but i think a b would [ __ ]
absolutely not
if anyone here we all know who would be
zach would you [ __ ] yourself
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there it is
himself like
a hog on hog crime yeah but i'm a
beautiful person what do you want there
you go self love is important
guys please have a great fight we can't
wait to see you guys
thanks um
go for this are you go for the nose or
don't i've definitely gotten dad's head
we're thinking about the nose do we hit
it or not
it's gonna be i'm going all out all out
damn okay i don't know where i'm gonna
be hit i'm gonna be hitting everything i
can
that's fair
we'll see
if he dies he dies
all right guys he actually killed me
i i when you keep bringing that up and
he keeps these texting music you know
i'm a little nervous i might actually
die i think you're getting like
superstitious or whatever and then you
start
with my with my gravestone on it i feel
like you're like wheeling my death into
existence through that
it's it's a joke well abs trainer killed
a guy
i know i know all about baby's trainer
baby's gonna be lethal i i know abs
gonna do very well but what if you do
kill matt are you gonna feel bad about
the merch
well then a b on a previous episode like
last week he was talking about how 11
people in boxing die a year and only one
in mma dies a year and i was like oh my
god what if what if matt is one of the
11
i started
i'm actually worrying about this but i
know i don't have i mean i don't think i
have the power to kill someone he's got
a weak nose
yeah just like that's like my death star
hole it's like i mean he'll just jump up
he might just you know all right well
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna have
to wait and see yeah guys thank you for
calling in appreciate it both guys uh
you've got uh matt watson of super mega
you got dad of dad it's all happening in
a couple of weeks guys so keep keep
going all right we're rooting for both
of you somehow yep thank you thank you
you're both going to win if you guys
were against anyone else oh double know
yeah
we'd like you guys yeah we're hoping for
a double ko that's right just right
uh both simultaneous deaths is what
we're seeing
we'll see what we can do all right guys
take care thanks for calling thanks for
having me all right bye thanks
there you have it
love what god's name are you doing what
is that what the size of that beaker let
me see that is that a beaker or a cup
yes you're drinking out of a conquer
you guys don't have soft
what's the swedish thing wait what's up
in sweden we have like concentrated uh
basically soda pop without bubbles and
you pour
up to one with soft and then up to 10
with water you drink out of a beaker
wait you guys don't have that or all
that's so mind-blowing dude
i never
so is it just like the it's the syrup
from
soda but any drink
yeah it's not a soda they have their own
like brands this is carbonated lime and
cactus
from the light
it's called brand and you i pour the
soft to one water to 10 and it's like a
normal drink
i just think i just find the receptacle
funny yeah the drink right oh well i did
also want to take like the opportunity
to explain what soft is but yeah it's
just easy i mix it in here no glass no
dishes because my dad is making me make
do my own dishes and i don't have time
for that dads are the worst dude [ __ ]
that
no i'm just kidding shout out to your
dad love your dad shout out dude shout
out to dads everywhere did you do dishes
when you were uh when you were here love
when you're in america did you do dishes
you guys have a dishwasher we don't have
that okay in the waist you say that like
there was some i was just wondering i
don't know was there something because
did he leave dishes no no not yeah i
don't know i was asking well i've seen
camera at home
well cam would have to answer that uh
but for myself yeah i think we can
leave dishes
oh cam the game's in the restroom cam is
m.i.a
all right well anyway i gotta say i
think i'm really happy to meet matt
super nice guy yeah he's cool i'm a
little i am worried for matt
because dad is like a raging bull and
he's got that glass nose yeah the nose
thing yeah that sounds bad
i guess i mean a b has that problem yeah
i had a septoplasty and i got hit really
hard in the nose by my coach actually
when we were sparring and i couldn't
breathe out of it for like a week is it
better now i got hit a week later and i
think it it knocked it back into
playback yeah so there's a cure yeah
why doesn't you if you go to get a
surgery when the doctors punch you in
the face i don't know
i'm not sure
but yeah it was not fun
well
i mean
the age gap
is a that's a big factor i mean there's
a lot of years between those two but
obviously verse 26 but that is like a
freaking elite athlete yeah like
that's not a typical 41 year old by any
means so yeah it's hard to say
[Music]
well a nice call regardless
so let's talk about
what do we need to talk about we've got
beans we're going to talk about elon oh
let's talk about elon cause yeah let's
talk about euron
so did this just happen that uh well you
told me you had an update so elon musk
has been trying to buy twitter outright
i think the whole chain now
okay like right interesting live so the
whole chain of events is basically
that he put in like 10 billion dollars
to become the biggest shareholder
and then
he was going to join the board
but if you join the board of directors
you have fiduciary
duties like he went on twitter and
started talking mad [ __ ] about twitter
and if you're on the board of directors
you actually cannot
talk [ __ ] about twitter because you're
not allowed to
adversely affect the shareholders right
so he's like oh [ __ ] well i don't want
to be board of director then because i'm
not able to talk [ __ ]
about twitter so he said
i'm just going to buy twitter outright
he made an offer of 54
and 20 cents per share which is actually
38
over the premium of the company's share
price which is pretty
insane hey twitter world this is yours
truly and twitter was just announced
before we went live is accepting his
offer of 44 billion dollars
wow
so if you own twitter shares are you
getting paid out right now uh
yeah right yeah it's a buyout so yeah is
twitter in the s p 500 i don't know how
it's on nasdaq no i know it's on the
nasdaq but it's on the s p 500 oh oh um
because i don't think they even have
they don't have like income
uh right i think twitter has actually
only turned a profit like one year of
his existence
500 twitter stocks going up though well
yeah i mean on this news obviously
people won't buy it um i doubt it's on
the s p 500 but i don't know
i only say that because i own that some
s p 500 so i was like where's my check
elon
but uh
i don't think it is
so what's so what's the developing story
well the update that i mentioned was the
one that i already said it's that uh
trump came out and made a statement that
um
here here's the article right here i'll
throw it up on the screen
trump says he won't return to twitter if
account reinstated after must take over
he said on fox news apparently i was
just talking to dan about this trump
made this whole social media platform
called truth
and he has never [ __ ] tweeted from it
he only tweeted once to say stay tuned
guys there's lots more to come and he
has not tweeted on truth social
where is trump
what the [ __ ] is truth social
here this is his one okay
as far as i'm aware of his one and only
get ready your favorite president will
see you soon ghost just gone
so do you think trump i was just gonna
say trump could be unbanned by thursday
when we go live
yeah it's possible i mean he's saying
uh that
he will not return but i i find that
extremely hard to believe oh are you
kidding me that dude loved twitter
he's obsessed well i don't know why he
wouldn't maybe he just enjoys the
solitude he's like you know i realize
twitter's kind of toxic
i kind of just like the quiet
well elon musk says he wants to
transform twitter
as a platform for free speech around the
globe
and it requires vast improvements
uh he's gonna up he has a very novel
idea to add a edit button
which is pretty cool nobody's thought of
that
well in his [ __ ] pitch for what it
would be is one of the dumbest things
here i'll play this
on the edit button how how do you get
around the problem of so someone tweets
elon rocks and it's tweeted by two
million people
um and um and then then after that they
edit it elon sucks and uh
all those retweets
they're all embarrassed and how how do
you avoid yeah i mean it's so obvious
you basically put like a five minute
limit on the edit button because most
time you make a typo and then you notice
it immediately in like five minutes and
you're like oh [ __ ] five minute window
and also it needs a giant asterisk to
show the original version
pretty obvious all right pretty obvious
on twitter twitter blue the uh the paid
version of it you can do undo tweet and
you can set a timer you mean a race
yeah but
you put it not exactly you put a timer
on how long you want before the tweet
goes live right so that's not actually
it's not actually an edit button because
it the tweet doesn't actually go out
right yeah well you only realize it once
it goes out
right yeah right
on it right you can set a delay like if
you did [ __ ] up you you can well i'm
sorry but paying for twitter is the
dumbest thing i've ever heard well elon
musk just paid 44 billion for it so
still you know
twitter blue i mean when we're all
paying for so much crap so many
streaming services and you've got to pay
for twitter that type of
changing well here's here here's the
retweeters are exploited
well i think uh you know you don't have
the edit capability for a short period
of time and probably the thing to do at
upon the edit would be to zero out uh
all retweets and favorites
okay
i'm open to ideas though you know
on the edit button how so
that is literally just deleting your
[ __ ] tweet and tweeting a correction
he's saying remove likes and retweets or
making it possible to like and retweet
no no no it's like he meant by zero out
once he once you edit it once you you
tweet something a bunch of people
retweet it you edit it to be like ilama
sucks or whatever all of those retweets
and likes go back to zero yeah it's
the exact same [ __ ] thing as just
deleting yes
you'll keep the likes um
no he says zero out the light the likes
too yes go out uh all retweets and
favorites
okay favorites is is
zero out
zero out so yeah in that case it is just
deleting it
maybe he means hide but i don't know
but the point is that he hasn't he's
been talking about a [ __ ] adding an
edit button to twitter
for weeks at this point right when this
interview happens and then somebody asks
him a direct question of how you would
do it and he seemingly is
coming up with an answer on the spot
like he has not actually thought about
this for two seconds so this just broke
before we went live what is this trump
being held in contempt
former president trump in contempt for
failing to apply with subpoena related
to state attorney general
investigation in the trump organization
trump was ordered to turn over materials
sought by james
and will be fined ten thousand per day
until he does so
i mean 10 000 per day's a lot of money
but when you're a billionaire it's
literally meaningless like what's 10 000
times
365.
it's 365 000 right
no
no 3.6 million
well it's not just as simple as
continuing to pay the fees if you don't
after a certain period of time they'll
arrest you
you really think they're going to arrest
him i don't see it well i'm not saying
that that's going to happen but that
that whole like contempt in finding you
it's not just like indefinite like oh i
just don't have to do it if i just pay
10 000 a day forever like they'll
eventually uh
so the pressure is really on him right
now
he they're really going to find his ass
10 000 a day until he turns over the
documents maybe
i suppose so
i'm super skeptical
yeah i mean that does seem to be look a
court said turn over the [ __ ]
documents what do you mind
right
former president donald trump was held
in contempt of court by a new york judge
monday for not providing documents
subpoenaed by the state attorney general
trump will be fined ten thousand dollars
per day until he comply god he's red i
forget how red he looks
trump lost his fight against a subpoena
from state attorney general leticia
james then failed to produce all the
documents by a court ordered march 3
deadline later extended to march 31 at
his lawyer's request the judge ruled
contempt was appropriate because of
repeated failures to hand over the
materials
trump was not in the past his hair is
looking like extra crispy brawl
that's some ramen-ass looking dude it's
like bleached like straight up bleached
look at that color
dude he's been looking real interesting
lately did you see he did it he did that
it just bleached it's like bleached out
usually it had some color that looked
realistic but that's like justin
timberlake in the 2000s
what were you saying then
there was that interview with uh pierce
morgan
oh wait did that drop
or just the trailer
i think it went live by the way people
always say i gotta address this people
go oh trump did an agent office and and
joe biden's age trump literally he does
full makeup every day and he does like
judy biden's some old guy he doesn't
[ __ ] care about how he looks
he doesn't do all that trump literally
wears a face full of concealer and
makeup and
i mean he gained a ton of weight during
the office too i mean it yeah he would
look at before he definitely is a unit
he blew up
he had a blow up he's a unit bro
so wait let's see
it's exciting to get him back though oh
my goodness
so this this is what i'm saying
like the makeup does help especially on
camera but when you see it up close
you're like oh [ __ ] dude what and god's
[ __ ]
like you've seen those people sometimes
you go out and there's like a white dude
that just tanned so much they're they're
basically in black body
right right i mean trump is like he's
approaching bordering on blackface
this is before
yes
wow
you know he as as he starts to show age
in his face he's got to go darker and
darker to conceal it
how's the footage you can clearly see
around his his hairline and around his
eyes
right right that's my favorite is that
it's all white here you got like that
raccoon [ __ ]
oh man it's awesome i'm so down for
trump coming back we i i you know what i
mean
leftovers are gonna be off the road down
for him to come back on twitter right
not as president you know what i'm here
for all of it
well we might not have a choice in
either so we don't have a god i'm not
voting for him you know well yeah
obviously but like i'm not gonna be all
sad like last time i'm gonna be like
dude archer's gonna slap hard these next
four years leftovers is going to be off
the rails bro
oh god i miss it
oh god
yeah man
the thing is he's like so hateable it's
fun
it's like if james charles became
president
actually it is it is i mean
donald trump's committed more heinous uh
essays than james charles i think
like his whole career of it it's pretty
awesome yeah i mean james is a lot
younger he's got time to catch up but
yeah look at this this this this is what
that one is so epic
[Laughter]
yeah you know
the thing is holy [ __ ]
[Music]
i had a beat off
dude this is your masculine this is the
alpha male right here actually i've
heard it said that trump is really
progressive he he's really um normalized
men wearing makeup which is kind of a
beautiful thing yeah there you go
i feel so powerful it looks like he got
the surgery from face-off the nicholas
cage movie they swap faces with someone
it looks like he's on that show uh
uh what was the ice cube on where they
changed race oh black black white yeah
black white he's doing an episode of
block quiet dumps
dumps
i'm telling you man
you just come on you guys let's just
have fun with it
let's just let it all go to hell
and just have a good time
well again he's saying he won't be
coming back to twitter i don't believe
that for
two seconds i mean it's a big part of
his
campaign he posted his way into the
white house basically yeah
what are new york judges doing about
epstein and maxwell um
what
when people have like the american flag
around their name like that do you you
know something is going to
happen or you know you know
baby oh yeah amer yeah absolutely they
don't fly the american flag anymore it's
like yeah cause it's been co-opted by
like [ __ ] ultra nationalist white
supremacist freaks like when i was a kid
people used to fly the american flag on
veterans day and it was pretty normal to
see it it is normal to see it there's
nothing wrong with flying the americans
but like i'm sorry but
y'all some of y'all ruined it
you know
it's a little bit same with the swedish
flag honestly really yeah i've seen some
swedish people call me out when i do
like super swedish stuff
but you know i'm kind of just memeing
but yeah it's a little bit you know it's
too nationalistic it's like tone it down
yeah a little bit yeah it's okay to like
your country and be proud of your
country
you don't want to be
super proud
super in love with your country because
then [ __ ] goes sideways
well anyway elon musk
his little pet project of 40 billion
actually there's some things that i
think is a good idea he talked about
making people id themselves to get
verified which i think is interesting
i thought you already had to do that to
get a check mark
no he's going to open it up to the
public oh that anybody can get a
checkpoint if you
identify yourself and then so like
if everyone is
verifying their idea there'd be a lot
more like racist troll [ __ ]
uh yeah i mean i guess that just he
wants to
remove the element of anonymity from the
platform at least for
checkmark accounts um
and if
you know that expands to everybody
but it's not like you you don't have to
do that right like you can still no no
post without a check mark and be
annoying i think just opening it up
to the public yeah
so somebody
i seen people saying you know saving
this for later
um
he's really i feel like he's putting
himself in a lose-lose situation
everyone loves him now
mark my words
not everyone but like especially the
conservatives they're just like you and
there's a lot of people in the middle
too who are like elon we love elon he's
the man i feel like
mark my words
you cannot own twitter and be loved and
be beloved he just became a mod and
everybody hates mods
except our mods we love our mods oh a
mod he became a mod but you know that's
the stereotype is like the the mods suck
[ __ ] the mods or whatever and everyone's
a mod now he just he [ __ ] himself so
bad by buying twitter he flew too close
to the sun the guy feels invincible
everyone is going to hate his guts in a
year or two
because twitter
needs some regulation
otherwise it turns into a cesspool
and everybody
is going to justly or unjustly blame him
for whatever's happening
let's say marjorie taylor green
marger and taylor green post
you know the most obscene like an image
of like
a dead as a dead
muslim person just something that's like
so beyond the pale
twitter's gonna remove it rightfully and
then
the conservatives they turn it into a
whole new thing where
whatever happened is no longer what's
happening in their dialogue it's become
that i'm just saying he yeah whatever
goes wrong on twitter now he's gonna be
the blame and there's always gonna [ __ ]
go wrong on twitter he just [ __ ]
himself big time with this yeah he
staked out this position where he
explicitly says that he is a free speech
absolutist an absolutist that will not
hold true yeah it's just that's not a
tenable position uh especially running a
major social media company like really
there's gonna be a degree of moderation
and it's gonna piss somebody off
there's gonna there has to be a degree
i'm gonna be like you're a hypocrite i
thought you were an absolutist you can't
post uh kitty you can't post uh
right they're extreme they're obvious
extreme examples that it's like oh of
course we'll remove that but then where
do you draw the line and like it gets
complicated really fast
exactly
people are going to test the boundaries
and
he's really dumb for doing this in my
opinion
it's also you're spending 44 billion on
a company that's like never turned a
profit or is like barely ever turned a
profit i mean and maybe he'll be able to
turn it around
and start making money but but all of
the ways
all the ways to further monetize twitter
that's going to piss people off too you
know what i mean so
because everybody always gets mad you
know all of a sudden there's going to be
[ __ ] micro transactions twitter ever
makes a profit it will be done so to the
point where people don't want to use it
anymore right so
yeah he made a statement
um
some people are joking that he did he
spent 44 billion just to ban uh hassan
the other thing that joke or there's an
account that tracks all of his flights
yeah
i'd be interested to see if he bans that
kid
all right so here's his statement
free speech is the bedrock of a
functioning democracy and twitter is the
digital town square
where matter is vital to the future of
humanity are debated
that's generous
right you know i have we're talking
yeah hold the [ __ ] phone you're
talking about the twitter we're all on
where the [ __ ] is where are where are
meaningful debates happening on twitter
i miss that
uh mr musk said i also want to make
twitter better than ever by enhancing
the product with new features making the
algorithms open source to increase trust
i think that's interesting because you
see a lot of bitching about
shadow shadow banning which i don't
think is real
i've never thought it's real
it's probably real
i don't think it's as prevalent as
people think
definitely not there's definitely
automatic shadow banning for people who
spam and stuff yeah that takes you out
of that yeah i think to some degree that
probably does exist but if you make it
open source and you make the algorithm
open source it's going to be so easy to
game it like i think there's probably if
that's a
i don't know where i really land on that
debate because these algorithms are like
[ __ ] ruining our society and so like
i understand the impulse to want to make
it public but also making it public like
doesn't that make it way [ __ ] easier
to manipulate and write bots and like
all like there is an argument for why
these things are secrets you know uh
well i don't know the fear-mongering
psycho conspiracy theorists i feel like
the more open you are the more crazy
they're going to become anyway because
they'll be like look there's no such
thing as shadow banning they'll be like
sure [ __ ] face
just watched
defeating spam bots
and authenticating all humans
i mean in theory it doesn't sound bad
i'm kind of interested to see how it
goes but i know it's they're going to
turn on him but i am interested i'm
interested to see how it develops it
really isn't important i mean there
that's the thing like i'm fascinated i'm
interested i'm gonna eat popcorn while
watching this all go down
that being said
whatever is happening on twitter is very
insignificantly important to what's
happening you know in the world
but i am interested
the accountability aspect is definitely
interesting yeah it will change the way
people act authenticating all human
sounds great
for sure
the thing is people are you know yeah
twitter has tremendous potential i look
forward to working with the company
and the community of users to unlock it
okay
you know let's go let's do it i'm here
for it
i think it's i think it's ridiculous and
not that important
but i'm here for it right just saying
just saying
you know
i like elon musk he's like the most
important things are electric vehicles
colonizing mars and twitter
what about stealing memes elon what are
we doing about that
true crime
um
the real crime that's at the top of the
list yeah top priority we need to
authenticate memes
turn all memes into nfl i'm just going
to say i don't have to be in the
blockchain
yeah that's funny
[Music]
what do you guys think are you pro elon
buying uh twitter or
anti or you don't care paul
can we get a poll please
i'd be very interested to you know like
you see where he takes it yeah it's
gonna be great to watch it's gonna be
fun
interesting i mean
i think it's silly though i'm curious
how drastic it's going to change like
um
but yeah it's definitely interesting
historical
dan here's a nice comment
about you
they said
typhoon said dan you're my inspiration
i'm 17 and i want to be just like you
someday hopefully not bald though
[Applause]
you got him
nice
so well
keep on that grind go off king only 10
are for it tough crowd
yeah i mean i'm with you guys i'm either
i think it doesn't matter
versus i think it really doesn't matter
but since it's i i want i like it for
the same reason i want trump to become
president again you know
let's just get some stuff good i really
want him to become president again no
but if it's going to happen let's enjoy
the ride okay i mean yeah you can look
on the bright side of any situation but
uh
i don't i don't i wouldn't go so far as
to say i hope he becomes president again
for the people
like i said i wouldn't i'm voting
against him you could literally run a
[ __ ] human turd and i'd vote for that
you could you could you could run a
magic eight ball
and just just consult with that every
time there's nothing there's gonna be
for the magic kingdom that's what south
park did they did a little bit turd in a
douche
running against each other
he's just a mean machine i mean right on
the show
last year or whatever it was was so easy
because just every day giuliani is
melting on tv or oh that was that wasn't
that a great time giuliani melting in
front of a sex shop i mean that was
disgusting that was insane that would
those were those like three-month period
was so crazy although the culmination of
that was like the january 6 thing so
that was not awesome
it took a little bit of a dark time
i don't want that none of that that's
not funny memes that's horrific right
anal sex oh was it banger episode though
not playing but it was scary
well apparently it was actually
i just learned this i was watching um
oan and apparently it was all antifa
that was there that day you know i've
heard similar things it was actually all
antiques heard similar things
turns out we had that all wrong
well there you go i don't really know
you know i i don't i'm honestly not an
elon fan uh
but um
i've seen a lot of people really
freaking out about this
i i'm leaning towards the it doesn't
really matter
as well
i mean this is nothing like it's just
twitter twitter is not that important
guys twitter isn't that important i
think the the fallacy is we start to
think twitter is important clearly elon
musk has bought into that narrative yeah
he's absolutely twitter is not that
important nothing important happens on
twitter the only thing that ever has
consequence of twitter is when people
post something so dumb on twitter it
ruins their life which you see sometimes
but twitter is not important nothing
good has any i mean just genuinely
speaking it's just if twitter erased
tomorrow the world would have zero
consequence
i truly believe that yeah
and in fact that might be the good that
might be the best outcome of elon buying
he'd
i
changed my opinion overnight if he did
that
awesome
all right
be sweet
but yeah i mean like mega rich
billionaire guy owning
media company or
social media company this is not
anything new to society whatsoever uh
he is far from the first
to do this and yeah i guess it really
yeah it comes down into
how much you think that twitter is like
a genuine he seems to think it is the
modern day
public square where all public debate
happens and and you know it's it's the
most important influential social media
platform so if you believe that
then nobody believes you could see this
as a big move guys when have you ever
seen a nuanced
interesting conversation on twitter like
genuinely one time
it was it was about um
movie posters
about like uh
underrated movie posters or something it
was pretty amazing time square i got
lost town square status
you heard it here movie posters
uh
i mean it's kind of an obvious take
maybe even low hanging fruit but
if you have 44 billion dollars to spare
and your whole shtick is caring about
humanity and humanity forward and stuff
there's got to be a better use for that
money
right 44 billion dollars you got to be a
better use for that money yeah i think
so probably two things
you think of a couple
44 billion
like you could build public housing
basically
in every major
military
metropolitan city i would think with
that much money
i don't know maybe 44 billion dollars
isn't that much money
when you get on the grand scale of
national debt you know
talking about like trillions of dollars
oh sure i mean the us government spends
44 billion on a [ __ ] jet plane that
crashes into the ocean in a month you
know what i mean
but
it's definitely a different scale
but yeah
there are
likely far better uses
of that kind of money than but mark my
words the one thing i am predicting at
is this is that he is going to regret
this it is going to ruin his reputation
and everybody is going to hate him after
a year after he takes over is going to
be universal disdain for elon musk
result chris and and by the way he's
been [ __ ] on bill gates
you know how everyone turned on bill
gates well
i'm telling you now by the time elon
buys twitter and finishes his whole
[ __ ] posting career
he is going to crescendo
with being absolutely canceled ruined
and reviled by every person on this
planet mark my words and everybody loves
that too they go
whoa they love that whole batman quote
uh
well what's the batman quote they say
whenever when anyone does anything
i'd die the hero or live long enough to
become that's it he's 100 gonna be
he's going to live long enough to be the
villain
just wait and remember what i said he's
gonna be the most hated man
one of the most hated men by the time
he's over mark my words we live in a
society you think that's what he'll uh
transform into what do you think he'll
transform the the batman to we live into
in a society
that's what he's going to say
yes
say what never mind i know what you're i
know the two references you're doing
but together i'm having trouble with
this is he gonna become the joker
i guess i don't know
but yeah no that's interesting concept i
didn't think of prior i mean he
definitely just made himself a huge
target for everyone on twitter everyone
that loves him for buying twitter is
going to hate his guts
because twitter needs moderation
i know a lot of you already hate him
this is a left-leaning podcast right
like a lot of us already dislike him but
the people that love him and there is a
lot right now who are celebrating him
are going to [ __ ] hate his guts
because he has to moderate twitter
he has to
no you're living
and it just turns into [ __ ]
4chan essentially and
completely and then they're going to
hate him for that right so
you know
it's it's a lose-lose he got himself
into the worst
situation through pure ego and i'm just
telling you
everyone's gonna hate his guts with
peace and love
also i'm pretty sure he's actually just
a really shitty guy and as more people
turn on him there's gonna be lots of
like
hit pieces that are going to come out
ex significant others
ex-employees shady business dealings
it's all going to come out as people
dislike him more and more
especially the conservatives and i'm
just telling you man this is it this is
the end of of a good guy elon
just saying just saying
let's see remember i said that
just saying just saying
i really want to talk about this ace
family update this is my probably my
favorite thing we've found
of this episode that i've been wanting
to talk about i got to pee really bad
i'm just going to go pee and come back
and i really got you guys really have to
see this ace family update it's good it
is so good it's good i'll be right back
okay
oh
right away with the nice soft piano
music
what do we got dan it's lovely what are
we this is now a uh
weekend npr podcast
hello
welcome
to the h3 podcast it's very soothing
i'm joined here today
by a.b
zach how you doing
good evening ian
and love are you playing [ __ ] world
of warcraft what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
[Music]
bruh i'm trying to do a [ __ ] show
here hit the button what the [ __ ] are
you doing get the [ __ ] button
[Music]
he's censored he's out
i'm calling you a little musk dude
[Music]
not okay
love you better eat that [ __ ] fifa
fish dude
you're all right dude i'll be 500 bucks
richer my next next show
level what's the uh mtv jams angle
i mean just kind of kind of uh
a vibe i don't know you know it's sick i
was just curious
i got the tie today as you can see
nice with the post malone shirt hell
yeah everything
just kind of felt the the angle with
this uh
with this you know with these clothes
you know they call that a dutch angle
yeah what do you think of the dutch
you know i thought about bringing that
up but no people yeah i don't think he
has any problem with the dutch who do
you have beef with it's the danes the
other day i mean it's like kind of like
a friendly beef you know
but uh i mean when when we're talking
like the world europeans got each
other's back we love each other
and when we're talking about europe uh
the northern countries got their each
other's back like that what do you guys
call
all northern countries in europe in
america
um but scandinavian countries
scandinavia yeah yeah
we got our back so at the end of the day
we're brothers and sisters so i don't
hate them that's an overstatement what
the hecking dog
oh love
all love
[Music]
i kind of love the idea of just [ __ ]
with love shot cause he's always messing
and messing around in the background of
mine so i kind of like the idea of just
planning some stuff out to mess with his
she's playing [ __ ] wow
i'm actually just afk's farming but i
want to show you guys
8505.050
boss is almost back
hide that [ __ ]
yeah that's just that's a stash that
[ __ ] that's that [ __ ] right i hear him
he's talking about the sausage rolls oh
you got him so you got good time
canadians do not in all caps eat beans
on toast peace and love you know what
there was a lot of canadians in the chat
saying otherwise so you need to take it
up with them megan
megan
okay
uh somebody said uh
i was looking for a birthday thing oh
here it is cath
guys it's my friend patricia's birthday
please shout out patty
lots of love for you all happy birthday
patty shout out to daddy birthday puppy
patty
patty mayonnaise i got some sausage and
bangers or whatever that's called
oh yeah
and sausage in a blanket what do they
call it
i don't know i like it sausage rolls oh
sausage
sausage rolls that's such a normal name
for them it's always like a piggy and a
piggy and a big ben
bubbles and squake it's called a merry
it's got a
a little crumpet in the chimney my
boy can i get one of them
geppetto in the pit of the whale's
stomach boy
[Music]
then i got one of them flippy flopper
dropper
boys like james corden
oh hey
hey bro
can i get one of them dracula in the
coffin
but it's just about to be dark again eh
i don't know sorry
we need some
english people in here
playing world of warcraft no
what do you mean
absolutely no
whoa whoa whoa
let me see that
why are you playing world of warcraft
something happened in the game
well i'm afk for me i just have it on on
the second screen here
you're afk farming what does that mean
honor points
there's this bg that i can just afk in
while we do the show oh you're one of
those guys
yeah so that means you're on a team but
you're not participating in the battle
right yeah but they have this like
special brawl for this week where you're
playing against ais
so they can win when they're only nine
easy like actually very easy okay so i'm
not getting a new expansion come out or
something why are you playing
uh no i well i'm preparing for the new
expansion it's gonna come out in a
couple months
are you really hyped for that
uh i mean i'm prepared to be
disappointed but
i'm kinda hyped i've been playing wow
since i was a child so yeah
always try it out a little bit at the
start of the experience what are you
farming for what are you gonna spend
that honor on
uh just just pvp gear so i can own some
scrubs later right of course yeah
of course
all right let's talk about ace fest
oh yeah so we've been we've had a lot of
questions about
um how are they going to afford
to put on this massive festival
and somebody really figured it out that
pretty much explains everything
so check this out
ace fest
is on
july 9th
let me open it it's a little low res
that's the best i got for resolution
at the same exact location there's a big
festival
called the antelope valley summer of
soul festival
same location
same time
admission costs 15 bucks
ace families
is 100 per ticket and you have to buy a
minimum of three right
it's at the same exact spot here you can
see when they were touring the
fairgrounds
same building
there's no question about it
it's definitely
they're selling tickets to the to the
summer of seoul festival
sure would have marked up about five or
six times yep
because they're talking about how
we're gonna have free prizes free games
all these rides and we're like the
economics of that make no [ __ ] sense
and here it is
this explains it
um
so basically what they're doing
is reselling tickets to this event
which is a large festival
marked up like a gajillion times and i
think what they're going to do
is just do a meet and greet there
at the existing festival right
which is so [ __ ] crazy that they're
doing this you can go there for 15 bucks
and they're making you spend 300 minimum
to go meet them and [ __ ] lancaster by
the way it's not even in palmdale it's
actually in lancaster right yeah
you got to go do a meet and greet in
lancaster the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere in july
what's the average temperature in
lancaster in july it's got to be a
hundred like it's over yeah
what is it july 9th
i mean it's so dishonest it's so
oh what happened my thing got off high
of 98 to a low of 64.
yeah that sounds about right wait what
happened to the screen are you seeing
that
it's all fuzzy on my oh maybe it's just
the tv
oh it's better now
so
this explains everything
um
so what i think is actually happening if
i had to guess
is that they're partnered with the
summer of seoul festival which is
probably a normal thing a lot of people
probably part more with this so they can
give
tickets to clients or communities
something like that and so they became
an official partner
and they probably just buy tickets from
them for 15 bucks that they can resell
or
it could even be that they get tickets
for less than 15 bucks or even free
because they just want people to come
out right so
it could be that
they're not even paying 15 bucks for
them
and they're selling them for three three
to five hundred dollars
which again explains because they're
gonna make off like with two three
hundred thousand dollars that's crazy
bro because we calculated they're gonna
bring in like two three hundred thousand
in revenue this means they have zero
expenses
zero so that explains to me why it's
worth it to go through this whole scam
that they're doing this whole fraud yeah
because they're just going to pocket 100
of that they don't have any costs
they're not actually putting on a
festival
that's amazing
dude these people they are like
high-level criminal fraudsters
i would never dream that this was
actually what was happening
so yeah they're gonna just pocket a few
hundred thousand dollars so of course
it's worth it for them yeah
holy [ __ ] you guys can you believe this
and you know
we bought the package deal
so
i guess you could say
in reality
we got scammed yeah
scammed
i wonder if we could sue them for fraud
because there was i feel like some
deception and
yeah
there was no disclosure that you know
this was an existing
festival and
by the way this is 100 what's happening
in fact
sam you called the venue right because
we want to get more info how was that
call for
you um and
i said hey i'm i'm just looking to get
some information about an event in july
and they said ace fest
were inundated with calls every day
about this oh like they were super
irritated about it i think the reason is
because this story broke off yeah the
stromach and who were we were giving a
shout out to what was his name cat mad
catster so mad catster once again broke
this story
and when he called which was just like a
day or two ago
this i think he broke the story because
they were like putting him on hold they
didn't know what he was talking about
right and so i think once his came out
then a lot of people were kind of trying
to investigate
so
go ahead sam so they're getting lots of
calls
yeah yeah and so
the lady i spoke to couldn't really give
me any information she forwarded me to
the manager and i left a message for her
she's not in so
i'm interested to see if she calls me
back well i think a lot of people
calling people who bought this of
tickets to this event and they want to
know what the hell is going on i mean we
bought tickets right did you tell them
what did you tell them sam i i didn't
say anymore i just told them i just left
a message for the
the
event manager so disneyland meets
coachella
they're selling tickets to someone
else's event
ace family is a one day festival for
people of all ages
the ace fest has a variety of free games
free rides free prides and live
performances think of this festival as
the ultimate family playground for you
and your loved ones
it's not even
it's it's not even their event guys yeah
and what's curious is
i saw some people pointing out but the
actual event
the uh what's it called it's a similar
language right
except they there's no mentions of rides
i don't think that there's rides at that
event
so
i'm not sure oh that's interesting i
mean you'd think that they would false
advertising trust me you'd think they'd
uh definitely put that out there if that
was part
of the actual
you know festival ever event everyone
who bought tickets to go for a ride dan
trust me that yeah they're going to take
them out of their lifetime that's right
but i just can't go you can buy tickets
to this event for 15 bucks
so you're paying a hundred dollars per
person to drive out to the middle of
nowhere
and oh god awful deadly uh
weather to take a picture hope maybe
with
ace fam this is what you guys can expect
cars
tons of dude dude look how hot that
looks yeah the black asphalt
that is going to be so hard
i mean it's a ways out but it is it is
projected to be
uh a hundred degrees on july 9th on uh
accuweather right now so by the way it
is in lancaster they lied and said it's
in palmdale
you know was that to throw people off
maybe definitely throw off the trail
definitely 100
it's in lancaster
[Music]
so there it doesn't look like there are
rides actually
yeah i
saw no signs of any rides
i bet you can just rent rides very cheap
like from some kind of a
company they said free ride no i don't
think you think so so you think that
i i think the only way this makes sense
is if the ace family's not spending any
money
in my opinion i don't think they're
spending a dollar they're basically just
it's like an affiliate program they're
you know
helping to sell tickets and in return
they get like a booth where they can do
their meet and greet i think so that's
what i think is going on yeah
it might be
actually
but i'm i'm really curious
yeah it says call to become a vendor
limited space available don't miss out
so they're probably just a vendor right
that would make sense
yo but the people that show up are gonna
be so pissed they just they're just ven
just vendors where people can take
photos with them they'll probably try to
sell them merch too huh yeah i mean
nothing there is going to be branded as
ace fest of course not anybody that's
like not following this drama and bought
a ticket and they show up on the day and
they're just going to be really confused
but also they said free parking but here
it says parking is five bucks
maybe that's part of the affiliate
program maybe that they it's like a but
there's no receipt we bought the tickets
right we didn't get parking we didn't
get a barcode that is true i think
they're gonna have to pay for parking
that's epic
i think they will
well we'll find out we're definitely
going
oh this is this is amazing this this to
me
this is my watergate
this to me is one of the most
interesting things we're gonna follow
all year
i i just can't wait to see how this
unfolds
you know
well we were going to try to get a booth
next to theirs and do h3 fest
and like donate the money to charity
what do you think
might be harder now that this whole
controversy is happening you know
if sam wasn't even able to get in i
wonder if they're gonna cancel the ace
fest
it's hard to say i don't know dude this
is this isn't this so good so
entertaining so interesting
oh well let's watch um catcasters
mad casters he called before anyone else
and actually got someone on the phone
and got this really incredible scoop
the person gives her name and i don't
want to reveal her identity so basically
what i said was look i have a ticket for
this event that's coming up on july 9th
but i don't see it on your calendar
online so i'm a little concerned because
there's a deadline coming up for
cancellations and if this event is not
really booked then i want to ask for my
money back so she said well let me take
a look and i will get back to in a
second so she put me on hold for i don't
know seven or eight minutes and then she
did finally come back and basically she
confirmed to me that there are some
youtubers booking a carnival for that
date for july 9th they are in the
carnival lot so apparently they have a
carnival lot
but
listen to this hi i'm trying to confirm
the date of an event i bought a ticket
for but i don't see it on your website
the ace fest on july 9th is july 9th the
correct date i just was a little
concerned when i looked on your thing
it's not there uh on my calendar and i'm
going to tell you my calendar isn't put
out yeah i have an art festival
and that's in the carnival lot
i appreciate it so so but there is
there's something booked for the
carnival lot but it's an art fest and i
know something else is going on there
but i i thought it was supposed to be a
um something
somebody from like youtube or youtube oh
yeah that would be the ace fest okay
so so it is but it is going to be
that's okay
i don't know i appreciate your i got
scared because i'm like oh my god is
this a scam you show you do show that
something is being booked yeah and i
know that this art festival is is just
going to go into that film
okay so they're like sharing the space
yeah okay all right that's good that's
all i need i i feel better now thank you
so much for your help
you did some kind of voice yeah
but i just was concerned that they have
this deadline coming because it's
illegal oh my god to record him without
telling him
uh
well in california actually that is true
not my problem look i've got better ass
for my money back but i appreciate your
help so i i know you're busy and i
really do appreciate it thank you very
much so anyway so basically she
confirmed to me that there's an art
festival booked for that same day july
9th in the carnival lot but also
apparently the ace family has booked
space also in the carnival lot
so the ace family and i confirmed this
with her and you heard that a second ago
the ace family is sharing this carnival
lot with this big art festival how
that's going to work i have no idea but
the both events i guess are going to be
going on at the same time so right away
that's kind of weird that they're
sharing space with an art festival but
also it certainly doesn't sound like
they booked as much space to accommodate
50 000 people or whatever they were
talking about in that video they just
showed but so i can confirm that the ace
family has reserved or has become the
process of reserving space at the av and
event center but that they are outside
in the carnival lot sharing space with
an art festival on july 9th how it's
going to play out we have to wait and
see
whether or not they'll sell many more
tickets when they change the ticket
structure we'll have to wait and see
crystals tell her that they're going to
sell out but um or that they're let me
take that back that they're going to be
able to expand
so anyway this from madcatzer
and um
i'm super excited i'm super pumped
who's going we got five tickets who's
going oh we haven't locked that in yet
but i imagine uh i mean
it is on a weekend right this isn't like
in the middle of the week what is july
9th can you imagine that one of them
i think it was a saturday
yeah i assume it's on saturday uh yeah i
mean it'll probably
be me and for the
crew
i could just shoot ian and cam too i
ride with that
you got five tickets maybe a big
advantage realistically like we all
could just walk in this place that's
that's mine
15 bucks
i'll just go to the i'll go to the art
festival next door
yeah that actually sounds good it's on a
saturday so
damn gonna make that happen man
so this is really exciting and i like
all the updates
so good
um
there's another discussion who's
discussing this there's a subreddit
called ace family snark
oh really this is just like all it's a
dedicated
subreddit
huh
um what do you see that on the tv can
the audience see that it's all fuzzy
uh it seems fine on my screen right ian
you're good okay so something weird is
going with the tv yeah
well there you go that's that there's
this other thing called the the brand
family but let's talk about that on
wednesday because i really have to go to
the bathroom we're pretty much at the
end of the show
so thank you everyone for watching yes
thank you to matt
watson and dad what a great conversation
very excited thank you to the to all the
people of the queen's
uh countries for
your fine cuisine
beans and toast forever
this is
ethan klein we'll see you on wednesday
[Music]
so
[Music]
you